in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is an executive session of the
committee
please note there is no physical
connection for members of the public to
observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i am confirming that all the members of
the committee and select legislative
staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to listen
contemporaneously
by means of the zoom platform or
telephone
all necessary information has been made
available in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
notice for this meeting complies with
house rules
and rsa 91a anyone who has problems
accessing the meeting should call 271
3600 or email
h c s at l e g
dot state dot n h
dot u s in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled
christina daya committee researcher will
be staff assisting us
please note that all votes to be taken
during this meeting
shall be done by roll call we'll start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states his
or her
presence please also state whether there
is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting this is required
under the right to know
law would the clerk please call the roll
thank you
representative mcmahon president
and no one's in the room with me um at
my office at home
representative nelson president here in
brookfield and i am alone
representative acton i'm here
in fremont and i'm alone in the house
representative gay
president representative cushman
president
representative folsom president
representative kelsey
president representative king here
in the lobby representative kobalt
i am here in my home office in wilton
there are others in the house no one
else in the room
representative weber here in my home in
walpole and i am alone at home
representative mckay president of the
llb
i haven't done representative cannon yet
representative query who are you sitting
in for today
i'm sitting in for representative
merchant
okay um representative knurk
i'm here alone in my study in freedom my
wife is in the house but not in here and
unfortunately i do not have my
grandchild
represent this subway uh present in my
home office
in lee new hampshire and alone
i'm home alone in my home in somersworth
representative mutter-uppam good morning
i'm
here in my living room in nashua new
hampshire and
my husband is elsewhere in the house
alone in my office home at home
in keene representative woods
i'm here in my uh study
in beau i'm alone in my study but my
wife is elsewhere in the house
representative cleary present i am here
in manchester new hampshire
and my grandparents are in the house but
not in the room
and representative pearson here in the
lop
we have two accents who is absent
i'm opening the executive session on
senate bill 74
relative to advanced directives for
health care
and the chair calls on representative
gay
i make the motion to retain
sb 74. representative gay moves to
retain
hb 74 do i have a second representative
cushman representative gay would you
speak to your motion please
yes um i think this is a very very
important bill
it needs to pass in the current form
it the wording is so loose that many
many people
are interpreting it as a euthanasia bill
there's several places we can fix the
wording so that it's much more
clear and it retains the rights
[Music]
weber
you mr chairman i'm very
concerned that there has been a very
concerted last minute effort
on this bill which has been worked on by
many many people
the identification of it as a euthanasia
bill
is simply incorrect because there's a
specific
statement in the bill stating
that nothing in this bill authorizes
that
the other concerns that i have heard
with it
is that it is too complicated and of
course it is
complicated because end-of-life issues
are always
complicated for all of us
it says that it excessively loosens end
of decision
end-of-life decision-making rules it
does not
uh it allows people
to make their own choices for themselves
and in the event that they have not done
so
uh they it it
has a framework for making sure that the
nearest
and dearest to them have a voice
in what happens to them obviously
if that doesn't you know if there is
if there is dissension or if there's
concern about whose making the decisions
there's always a court proceeding but
it says it inappropriately authorizes
new players well no it doesn't these are
the same players that are involved in
these decisions anyway
and then concerns about
lacks any clear opt-out provision well
there's a very clear opt-out provision
you simply do your own directive
and tell people exactly what you want
and exactly who you want involved in the
decision making process
so i think this is a very important bill
it is a
very well thought out bill i think it is
very unfortunate that people who did not
come
to any to the or hearing or
start any kind of opposition until
over the weekend um are
are working hard to torpedo the work
that's been done already so
i am hoping that a motion of
ought to pass may be brought if the
retention is overturned thank you
thank you representative
who else has a handout representative
woods
representative thank you mr chair
um i'm a co-sponsor on this bill as you
can see
um i've been involved with this uh
in many dimensions over um since the 60s
basically
as a house officer i was thrust into
position on a couple of times when i
worked in the intensive care unit
where there was there was no help
in this regard as we're looking at now
i've seen this developed i've helped it
peripherally through being a delegate to
the ama
american medical association and through
the
new hampshire medical society uh this
has been
um a very very concerted effort um
um and it's it's not perfect
um and uh for that reason there's always
going to be some changes as use
comes along the way um we'll find ways
that
will need to be changed at this juncture
i would have absolutely no problem uh
with retaining it
uh if i could find if there are some uh
very concrete
areas uh that can be specifically
uh uh examined and i would i would be
very happy to be part of that group to
work on it uh in that guys um
but has been alluded to already
uh the myriad of people who have
addressed us have been in very vague
terms
uh and when they have addressed uh
supposedly specific items uh they
clearly have not read uh
the bill um so i'm i'm i'm
i would like to retain it and work on it
if there are specific
things to work on uh and if it were
retained
uh then i would uh put my shoulder to
the task
and i would only retain it if we had
an honest commitment to do that with
specific
entities in mind again i have not seen
that yet
but i would like to hear some even at
this moment
if we could but this has been a good
bill
it's come a long way i look at it from
two perspectives
that if we um
uh when we pass a piece of legislation
uh any piece of legislation for that
matter
uh are we doing harm in any way by
unintended consequences
uh or are we doing harm by not passing
it
would we be helping more by passing it
at this juncture
at this juncture i can see that passing
it would be of more benefit
but if it were retained i could be
happy with that if if if
we have some very specific items that
need to be addressed
thank you mr chair thank you
representative representative soloway
thank you mr chair um like to speak
against the motion to retain
i've put deep deep thought into this
and i've conferenced with members of
this committee
on both sides and have dare i say
agonized over it
i do not wish to contest the quality of
the bill i think that the senate
and this committee have done yeoman work
in crafting the best possible bill
for the moment what i would like to
speak to is the political process
and the political process is uh that
many of us
who are committed to the content of the
bill
um do not wish to risk the bill
being rejected by the full house however
the fact of the matter is
that the full house does represent the
will of the people
and it's time to let the full house make
its own decision
about otp or itl or tabling
this motion and i would like to see an
otp motion
come out of this committee thank you mr
chair thank you representative
is there anyone else i see your hand but
i don't see your face
uh clerk representative canark who has
apologies there we are yep i would like
to echo what has previously been said
um i have received also a number of
emails all of which represented that uh
demonstrated that apparently the
offender had not looked at the bill
and um you know again the whole issue
that it allows
assisted suicide if we look on page 24
lines 23-25 nothing in this chapter
should be construed to legalize
constitute
condone authorize or approve suicide
assisted suicide mercy killing or
euthanasia
i don't know how much more clearly that
can be stated
that isn't even confusing legalese
that's plain english
so i would echo what representative
woods said i've also heard that people
have concerns about it well then
right now in this committee please give
some examples of where it is confusing
wordy because some of the examples
were brought up during the hearing and
those were explained
and they were quite clear and there was
not a confusion
i think that anybody who wants to vote
for retaining this
should uh be able to see that as
representative woods just said
that there are some clear flaws and so i
would invite
those who favor retaining to demonstrate
those at this point in time
to convince those of us who want to
actually have an ought to pass
motion to think about retention
if we can see clear flaws that can be
addressed
in absence of that i think also yes we
should
pass to get this bill out of this
committee as an ought to pass
and as representative salloway said let
the full house
vote on it thank you thank you by the
way i should
i should also add the fact that the
catholic diocese is on board with this
and they are pretty smart and they think
well
and we're quite convinced that they do
not support
assisted suicide and the fact that they
are on board with this means
that it has i think a good stamp of
approval that it is a good
well thought out bill thank you thank
you representative do we have anyone
else who's
uh in the meeting via zoom who wishes to
speak
no i don't see any humans
okay i don't see anybody anybody in the
committee room who will switch to speak
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman um so
my my concern is not that this bill is a
euthanasia bill
um but that its intention was to clarify
language
and make some other provisions but um
clearly from all these emails
it's it's not clear to other you know to
some of our stakeholders you know that
this bill would affect
um specifically bobby schindler
terry schago's brother if you remember
the case of terry scheibel she was a
woman with a traumatic brain injury
and her nutrition and hydration was
stopped by a court order
against the family's wishes he sent us
an email
asking us to icl the bill and
i think his testimony if you guys uh
take a look at it is pretty
um you know profound but my reasons
um striking the language on page six
lines 36 and 37
um and page seven lines one through
three making it so that
the um choosing to have one's wishes
overwritten
should you no longer have the capacity
for decision making
instead of needing an explicit statement
in the advanced directive i think this
means deeper
consideration and tightening of the
proposed language
and while i can see some situations
where that could be necessary
um such as in a person who has dementia
who's refusing showers
um there are other situations where you
know this would be
problematic such as someone who has a
traumatic brain injury or
another acute injury or illness that can
cause a transient state of incapacity
for medical decision making
it would be difficult for them to
resume um the capability to
to decide for themselves in that
scenario
section five there's a measure to allow
surrogates or agents consent to
clinical trials for experimental
treatments
not only just intended to save their
life but to quote reduce
pain distress or discomfort i think this
language is very broad
and opens the door to virtually any
medication trial for any diagnosis a
patient has which many patients have
many diagnoses um so you know that could
include a clinical trial for any
simple things such as hyperlipidemia or
heartburn
to you know a vaccination for a disease
likely to cause discomfort any disease
you know
maybe one that's not even deadly so we
need to be very careful here
um the form for advanced directives and
disclosure statement has some issues
the disclosure statement claims that the
default position
is your agent can consent to enroll you
in clinical trials but
you may write otherwise and the advanced
directive form which is signed
leaves out language on the current form
that says
i hereby acknowledge that i've been
provided with the disclosure statement
explaining the effects of this directive
i have read and understand the
information contained in the disclosure
statement
um as written in sb 74 it just says i
have received the disclosure statement
so not necessarily that you read and
on page 18 line six
the advanced directives are clarified by
crossing out and initially any
statements one disagrees with
i think this is confusing and it doesn't
lend to clarity at all
the section should have a box of the yes
or no or some other clear language
i do wish i do not wish with the option
to choose one or the other like the
present
there are a couple of others and i i
don't mind going through but
um just as a start you know that's
that's where some of the problematic
languages
thank you representative anyone else in
the world
wish to yes representative king
[Music]
thank you mr chairman
the um i just wanted to
make a point of clarification that uh
representative weber made reference to
is
uh this wasn't something that just came
together over the weekend
it was actually first presented to us at
the last committee meeting
by representative leahan and
um in her in her testimony
she lists uh several i think there's
like nine or ten things that uh she saw
wrong with the uh bill as as it
currently reads and
then uh at the end when we made a
a request on whether we wanted to
actually look into this
um representative gay had brought up
that
she wanted to put some language together
um
and then over the last two weeks um
there's been um you know
some research and further looking into
this bill so
it's hard to actually say that nobody's
actually read through this
i think um i think there's been a lot of
work put into
uh some of this and also some of their
discussions with
uh representative leon in her testimony
she says that she
wanted to kill this bill and um
you have actually gotten her to a point
where she would support a retaining
if that's what the committee feels so i
believe that um
i think retaining is definitely a good
option at this point that
i think all of us feel that this is a
good bill and that
we just need to look at some of the
further language and i do appreciate all
the work that's been put into it up to
this point it's just i think
that a little bit more needs to be put
into it thank you
thank you representative anyone else
then a few things from me um
as the chairman three reasons i would
support retention
i still do see confusion in this
language
and i have given copies of this world to
numbers of
friends who are quite intelligent and
about half of them have said
i don't see any confusion and the other
half of them say
i see numbers of places with confusion
secondly page
23 lines 30 and following
an agent or surrogate may revoke
a do not resuscitate or pulsed order for
a principal
who lacks capacity to make health care
decisions
there are numbers of people who wish to
deny that
that maybe the person was of clear mind
when he or she wrote that but is not
that now
but the orders were written or the
desire was made known
when the person was of capacity to make
a healthcare decision
and therefore numbers of us
believe that the surrogate does not have
should not have the right
to overrule that and then thirdly
i've come to these conclusions before
the barrage of
weekend emails i've read some of them
and um i don't agree with a number i
agree with their conclusions
but i do not agree with the
reasoning that got some of them there i
see
the statement about euthanasia as clear
as it possibly can be
so people who say that it is the
slippery slope to euthanasia
i don't see that at all the final reason
is i've been talking with numbers of
people in my party
recently i learned
not surprisingly that the freedom
republicans
want to stress the rights of the
individual for self-determination
and for reasons i just gave do not see
that self-determination as clear as it
is
in the laws of some states but if it
were just the freedom republicans
um i can do a nice count in voting
um the bill would probably pass but what
i have seen
is numbers of others who would not
really wish to identify
with the freedom caucus at all on most
things or many things
also have come to the same conclusion
and if the bill goes to the house floor
and is defeated it will come back next
year
and there's a number of things in this
bill
that are good and an improvement and i
wouldn't want to see that
and so rather than just passing it as is
with the problems i see or defeating it
which i would not wish i think the
motion to retain
is the one that i'm supporting
for me retaining a bill and there's
really no pun intended on this
is not death with dignity um motion to
retain
for me and knowing this committee is
let's really work on it let's polish it
until it shines
which is kind of like what we've been
doing all year so far
and i would very much want to put on uh
such
a um retained committee
uh people who generally favor the bill
but want to remove the roadblocks that
some of us face
so for that reason i would move to
routine
[Music]
my uh i've said many times my wife is my
eyes and ears
on the ground for medical issues she's
out there every day
uh as a home care physical therapist
helping people make these tough
decisions of transitioning from uh
from fighting a terrible disease to
hospice and she sees these problems
daily and it rips families apart and
it's
representative acton the representative
act and the people in the room really
can't
okay
stay on second here
all right i can i can speak up a little
bit louder here is that is that better
that's better thank you okay sorry about
that i i just i have a different
microphone
um just to recap my my wife as you all
know is my eyes and ears
as a home care physical therapist she
deals with the problems that we're
trying to
address here every single day and it's
it's
the time has come to to address these
problems we have to fix it now the
the amount of people that have gone in
in organizations and so forth
that have had input into this is
impressive um
and we've gotten to this point where we
have a
piece of legislation yes it's not
perfect like very few
pieces of legislation we ever deal with
this complex are going to be perfect
but what i see now is
and and certainly mr chairman i i
understand
your your um pledge of of doing
a real study on this if the time comes
but i just i just believe i resent that
this was turned into a
ideological choice
of of euthanasia when and
it's just it seems as though this is
just being killed it
an attempt is being made to kill this
an ideological bounds when this is a
problem that needs to be solved we need
to get on with it
retaining is just going to put it off
for another
another uh until next year and i just
don't see that that
that's the smart move i think we should
move to the
move to the floor and if if there needs
to be amendments
on the floor to address these these
individual issues which wouldn't
um be unprecedented then let's do it but
let's
let's make the move let's let's take the
immense amount of work being done
from across the entire industry really
of of medical care
and and let's let's make this happen and
if there's issues that pop up that we
can fix it next year with legislation
but i i'm just i've had it with
retaining things
with let's get proactive here let's move
this to the house
we can fight it out there no matter what
happens and take it from there
that's that's my belief thank you thank
you representative my response to
uh one of your comments is i certainly
do not see this as ideological i see
this as a matter of clarity
nor did i hear any of the uh my
colleagues
in the room speak that this is
a slippery slope i think we all agree
that euthanasia terms
irrespective of what emails came in over
the weekend the
euthanasia issue is very clear and um uh
again it's a matter of clarity but thank
you uh
for your testimony anyone else
a representative um nikki
if you look at the current advanced
directive form there is a section for
additional instructions which is large
and mentions instructions about refusing
any specific types
of treatment that are inconsistent with
your religious beliefs or are
unacceptable to you for any other reason
this section however does not exist on
the forum if
sb 74 passes as currently written
and then on page 25 line 6 it strikes
the ability for a patient's common-law
spouse as defined by rsa
457-39 to be deemed the patient
surrogate i don't have um all the
answers to these issues but despite the
staple they're spending so much time on
this
and then they are meaning well there are
some problems with this bill
i feel like truly i i like this bill but
i feel like that we need to fix the
issues now
so and not pass something that that can
die on the floor because then it can't
come back so i
this is why i would be in favor of
retaining this
thank you representative representative
gay
yes i didn't want to speak at length
when i first spoke so i wanted to add
there are several specific things that
need to be fixed
and i don't think waiting until we can
vote
again not in june the next time i don't
think for something that's been
decades in the making is a bad
investment of time
we want this bill to pass as soon as
possible
gets killed on the floor we lose it for
two years
and start over so i will say some more
specifics
it's not all of them but it's a couple
of specifics
and one is removing in several places
the role of the family has been put
lower than the role of the doctors
or pa's or um
nurse practitioners the family has been
left much lower in having authority to
determine
uh what the patient wants and also
[Music]
well i forgot the other thing but i mean
that's pretty critical
that the family is less important
[Music]
or that if you do sundowning where
they're clear in the morning
as the day gets in the evening that's
not the time to ask for something
important
um i've buried both of my patients and
both
my parents my husband's parents so
uh and as i get older i'm very concerned
about these patient rights i think we
have to go over it
find some phone and correct some wording
that's not badly intentioned except i do
think when you
say family is not near as important as a
as a surrogate i do think that
needs to change but i really think the
changes
are not really policy
i think they are inadvertent
to remove authority from the patient
the principal and their families
so it's you know i don't think it's fair
to say
this is prejudice i think we are all
concerned
about specifics that need to be
addressed and clarified and that is done
much better in work
sessions rather than an amendment here
and there
a lot of people in this committee were
on the committee that
came up with this bill most of us were
not
or we could have said this you know
months ago so we wouldn't be coming
after the fact and saying but wait a
minute we need to fix this
so i beg you let's fix it it needs to
pass
we need to make it clear if very
intelligent people can read this
and say this doesn't i don't know what
they're saying here
i have a real problem with the form i
think whenever you sign something you
want to be signing what you're
intending and if somebody says oh it
can't be more than a page or two
that's a bunch of baloney buy a house
you don't sign one or two pages
everything all the policy needs to be
in the document that you sign and maybe
that'll mean some of the
legalese that repeats and repeats and
repeats maybe that can be clarified
but when you sign something you should
not have to be referring
to another page another paragraph to see
what you're signing
so i want this bill to pass i just want
it to be
in good usable understandable form
i am not slamming anybody who worked on
building
on building this i know you put blood
sweat and tears and many hours
into it
[Music]
thank you representative is there anyone
else who wishes to speak do you see any
hands madam clerk
uh yes representative
thank you a couple of things to keep in
mind
one is that when you talk about the
forms
the language that is in this statute
says
uh components shall be substantially in
the
substantially the following form that
means that it is not going to have to be
absolutely verbatim what is in the bill
um so
issues if it's clearer with a check box
rather than a cross out an initial
that can be done these this is not
something where it has to be precisely
this
so those concerns can be addressed after
this bill is passed
but nothing can be done if the bill
isn't passed
uh likewise i the comments
um they were i was going to respond but
i couldn't keep track of everything
some of the issues that i think are
confusing to people the
uh i would like representative clarify
where the
family is placed below the practitioner
the practitioner i think that may be in
these places where he refers to who
writes the orders
and that's because a family can't go in
and write an order only the practitioner
can
but the family or whoever is the
designated sur
surrogate is the one who tells the
physician or the
sorry the practitioner what to write
only the practitioner right and that was
came up in the hearing it came up in the
hearing about why was that language
there
it has to do with who can actually write
an order in a chart
so that's important likewise the issue
about incompetence
we're you know we we frequently are
dealing with people
just think about your standard person
intubated in icu after a few days
most of them are not particularly able
to make good decisions at that point
they often become psychotic
and we they may want to try to pull
their tube out should we just let them
pull their tube out when they're
from have a perfectly reversible disease
that's what they want to do right then
but no we sedate them to keep them safe
so they don't pull their tube out so
they can recover
and then eventually turn back into the
same viable person they were
before they got that transient illness
so we're not talking about
when we say we not respect their wish at
that point they yank their tube out
it's because it's for their safety
obviously this goes into much more the
longer term issues
the issue too about terry schiavo's
brother i wonder whether he read this
bill indeed
there would not have been a court order
if they had an advance directive
i think it went to the court because
there was not an advance directive to
clarify what the
what the treatment should be to prevent
the problem with terri schiavo is
exactly why we have this and this bill
would have clarified with
certainty that if there were not an
advance directive
who the surrogate would be and that
surrogate
would have been the family it gives that
order
that sequence in the bill here about who
takes
first first second third and if they are
capable if they're not capable or
they're deceased or whatever
you go to the next one the family would
have been in charge
their problem would not have occurred
had this bill
for example been in effect when she had
her problem
so i still do not think i i'm still i i
guess i would go back and ask
could representative gay please identify
where it is that the family is placed
below the practitioner by page and line
so we can actually look at it rather
than just making the statement
without the backup thank you
thank you representative representative
gay yes
i will attempt to do that i have a few
places marked
and i don't know how great a job i'm
going to do explaining them
um let's see
page 23 line 16 and 17
about the flow of the family uh
requesting
transfer care if a provider has a moral
objection to a dnr
or we should be talking to a post um
i won't issue a post um
30.
um could i request the chapter number
because i'm reading it online
and it doesn't give the page numbers it
just gives the roman numerals
okay this is i'm not quite sure where
the
two roman numeral two is late and it's
on page 25
of 26 so i'm not quite sure what almost
at the very end yeah it's under 137 j35
welcome well it says roman numeral 2
yeah i don't see 12 but anyway
i'm sure that decision maker is
identified by the attending
practitioners may make health care
decisions for the patients
in accordance with rsa 137 j6
the surrogacy provisions of this chapter
shall take effect in the decision maker
names are reported in the medical record
so you
always have to get this put in the
medical record
the attendant practitioner
believes after reasonable inquiry that
neither a health care agent
under a durable power attorney for
health care or a surrogate
fire priority is available or able and
willing to act
so i left out a line they they can
change that person's uh the surrogate or
the
durable power of attorney if they think
they're not
willing to act which could mean
representative go ahead
that is not what it says it doesn't say
that they're not
uh by willing to act means
that you can find them it says only
after reasonable inquiry that neither a
health care agent or durable power of
attorney because if those two exist the
surrogate does not take effect
or a surrogate of higher priority in
other words you don't take the
third cousin and follow what they say
if the mother happens to be available
and you know that if you are aware that
the mother is available
and is willing to make that decision
they are the higher list
higher in that list than the third
cousin and therefore
they will be the one the person relies
upon and it does have a burden of
reasonable inquiry you don't just make a
willy-nilly decision
the practitioner has to do a reasonable
inquiry to find out
is there a health care agent is there a
durable power of attorney
is there a surrogate of higher priority
who is available
available means for example they're
still alive you can find them
they're not in some remote island uh it
has never been heard from for 20 years
they
the mother may be alive but not
available therefore they're unable or
unwilling
to act because they're not available and
also there are some people
who may choose they may just say look i
can't make this decision
i'd like to have my um
i'm speaking they may be the next in
line in surrogacy but they don't feel
comfortable making the decision because
they don't feel like they know what the
right decision is and they
they therefore they are not willing to
do that and they would pass it
to for example a child or a brother or
somebody else
who they think would be more competent
to do so
that is what that means it doesn't mean
the practitioner has the right to pick
who they have in fact it takes away
their right to just pick
and declares who they must rely upon
and that is according to the order of
well another really principal
really critical spot is uh
that only medical personnel are named in
here to determine
whether a person is
on who that practitioner is the last
time i was in the hospital i was shocked
that i wasn't going to see my own doctor
i was going to see the hospitalist now
maybe if we're talking about
a person in an assisted living or a
person
in a nursing home who the hospital is
scared to say no the hospitals
because that she takes care of all that
that's one situation
but it's only medical personnel who are
listed in here
to determine if somebody is a qualified
patient there is no reference to
any other kind of person which it could
be the family
and it could be their religious leader
it's just this is written very
clearly from medical care people's point
of view
it needs to be added the family's
point of view and it's not i'm not
inferring that there was a deliberate
attempt
to exclude the same it's accidental
it's an overlook it means the family
needs to be written
in here well there's another real simple
basic thing uh the list of
of potential service
doesn't list the commonwealth whites or
spouse
uh in a million other places common law
does have authority but not here
there are many many points like this and
i think they deserve to be discussed
and clarified you might be able to say
wait a minute you're not looking at this
right this is we wrote this and it is
clear
see this is what it means um
but i think they're just too many and
this is
not yeah i wasn't going to say death
with dignity because a lot of times we
retain bills we don't want to hurt the
people's feelings to
who issued the bill we don't want to
make them feel bad
oh we'll just study it later and then
just drop off into nowhere
this is critical this meets the past we
need to put it in good form
and not hope that we can come back and
clarify things
or address issues i think it be retained
because it is important
and this way a lot more people can have
input
thank you representative the chair
recognizes representative
weber
thank you mr chairman one of the things
that i
have been informed of over the course of
this discussion and i'm sorry i don't
have a site is
the there is legislative
authorization for life-saving clinical
trials
which expires in july that was temporary
emergency legislation
and if we do not pass this bill then
that authorization
for people to consent to that
life-saving trial
vanishes at that point so that's another
concern
for getting things done sooner rather
than later
and i just wanted to bring that to the
committee's attention thank you
representative before i
we continue with any discussion the
chair wishes to acknowledge
representative snow is
in the room thank you and do you wish to
speak
i just have a question um
i'm interested in representative
kelsey's
suggestion with commonwealth lives and
perhaps commonwealth husbands
i'm sort of excluded from that but how
do we define common law my
understanding is a common-law wife is
somebody who's lived
continuously with the same person for
over 10 years
um but does that mean that anybody that
was the west
i'm wondering if it actually excludes
common law wives
does it actually say they can't be named
it does not say
wise it says spouse and on page 25 line
6. it reads the parent spouse or civil
union partner
is the number one priority in the
decision-making order
it strikes the word or common-law spouse
as defined by rsa 457 colon 39.
it strikes common-law spouse so would
that satisfy your concern about that
phrase um i think represented so i think
that was representative gay that brought
up the common law
no i do understand i'm only asking the
question about that one issue
that's now covered well
[Music]
it's covered under the heading of civil
union partner
if they have done that if they
is i'm not clear as to whether a civil
union partner
is the new term for common-law spouse it
is not
then common-law spouse seems to be
stricken
now according to this bill but what what
does that mean
civil union israel for that i thought
they
just chose to live together and that's a
common thing nowadays that people don't
get married
but agree to live together and i thought
that's what that meant
representative kelsey thank you mr
chairman um so a civil union is
actually a it's it's a marriage i mean
it's a legal you know you would have um
it's a
ceremony but common law is just
essentially people that they're living
together
that choose not to get married and then
it's defined by that ten-year mark
so then they would have the same rights
as anybody that was
married so do we need to do we need to
look at a way of expanding that
definition
well this isn't going through the actual
is that what you're saying we should
expand that to include people who choose
to live together
and we have to put it i mean right now
the old definition was
common law meant you lived together for
10 years or longer
that seems like a pretty high god yeah
10 days is a high back
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman uh the rsa that's referenced in
the bill
um where common law spouse is defined
says
that it is considered persons cohabiting
and acknowledging each other as husband
and wife and generally reputed to be as
such for the period of three years
and until the decease of one of them
that they
shall there after they begin to have
been legally married
so representative snow that is stricken
now
in this bill and so this is why some of
us would argue for retention
that that no longer applies trent
that's correct stricken out online uh
page 25 line
six
anyone else mr chair
yes representative if i could just
circle back one thing which
it took me a moment to find the
reference and statute
um so that i could be certain about this
but
the conversation we just had a moment
ago about page 25
lines 19 to 27 and and even further on
where we talk about this uh surrogacy
and and relying upon which
surrogate and reasonable inquiry all of
that language
is currently in statute
it's not being added so concerns about
whether this is
something that should be there are not
an issue because
it's already there the reason it's being
changed you may recall
that in numerous spots through this bill
instead of saying the physician pa or
aprn
that was always stricken and changed to
the bold language which is
attending practitioner because that is
or just practitioner because that is now
the phrase that was chosen to be used in
this and the reason for that is again to
give a flexibility
in case there's some change in how we
define
who has the ability to be the
practitioner
and that attending practitioner is
defined early in the bill
but throughout the only thing changed
here and then there is the bold that
says in accordance the rsa 137 j6
which is the one that says you have to
honor the the um
preferences of the patient or of the
principle
that were explained to you or expressed
to you before so
all that discussion we just had about
changing this
is actually moot because it's not being
changed
it's already there and this is what
continues to bother me when see people
so i gave it to someone to read
well unless they read it and referred
back to each statute that's being
referred to
to read the statute and see what's there
they will be confused and there's an art
to reading through bills
and understanding the references and i
had multiple red marks
when i read this for myself and then i
found it later in the in the bill i said
aha it's defined
i don't have to worry about that and
could cross it off so
i would still say that i think the
language is clear
thank you thank you representative
representative snow
one of i i notice on page 25
line 15
there's a new term in there that i
hadn't seen before which is a close
friend of the patient
now i can't imagine a closer friend but
somebody you decide to live with and
share a life with
and would this not also cover gay
couples
who share a life together which and that
relationship
isn't as clearly defined but at least i
think you'd have to consider if two
individuals of the same sex were living
together they would
be considered close friends so it seems
to me they still could be considered
as a possible survey
it would be representative snow in my
reading of it except
on line five there is an order of
priority
and so a close friend of the patient is
priority h
in the priority order not priority a
as the equivalent to a spouse or civil
union partner
so that a person living together as
common law spouse would come in under
friend but
way down the list after uh relatives
so if that's what you want that's what
you've got but if you wish to see
common-law spouse
as being of equal priority as uh
actual spouse or civil union partner you
would want
to take the strikeout in line
six out but as it stands now
that person would be way down the list
uh representative folsom
um i basically was going to speak to the
same
exact point um chairman and that
in being unfortunately i know too many
people
who are not happy about their family
members
living with someone either of the same
or opposite sex and would find this as a
great opportunity
to uh cut them out process
thank you representative anyone else
can you raise your hands again
representative webber
and then nelson representative nelson
i'm just curious what happens when
there's a divorce
somebody's divorced or and you know dies
the next day
who makes a decision line seven says
unless there is a divorce proceedings
separation agreement or restraining
order
that would nullify uh what says before
patient spouse okay thank you
welcome representative webber thank you
mr chairman
with regard to the common law spouse
issue
currently our law defines a common law
spouse
as have somebody who has
been with the person until they
die so they're not the common law spouse
until after they're dead so
currently the law treats a common law
spouse
as a friend they don't have any priority
now
so uh they're not in a worse
position by us
passing this and of course the way you
fix that problem is you
have an advance directive and you
appoint that person as the person to
make
the decisions for you we are actually
protecting that
person more with this than they are
protected now
so that that's just my my
take on that one but i i certainly hope
that
we advance the bill but thank you
representative representative cushman
thank you mr chairman i uh maybe i'm
wrong with the way i read it is
that it's pretty clear
and it just says persons cohabitating
and acknowledging each other
as husband and wife and generally
reputed to be as such
one of the period of three years and
until the decease of one of them
representative snow wouldn't the some
priority be given i mean
we're asking the person who this affects
the person nearing the end of their life
to make some choices
it seems to me who they pick if it's a
close friend or someone like that
they would then be prioritized over any
of the other people involved would they
not
that's there they've stated in writing
and said that this is the person they
want
to be declared first and wouldn't that
take priority over anyone else
i think this just applies no one is
particularly
clearly named how do you then go down
the list
you give a brother priority over a
commonwealth but if the person
themselves
name who they want do it that would seem
to be the
main priority there is a place in this
representative folsom thank you um thank
you chairman uh
if the person has filled out the pulse
that's the perfect
time for them to put that friend's name
down because
i believe sometimes your friends know
better than sometimes your family does
um but this has to do with
picking a surrogate
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman
um so on the on this subject i
i think it was representative who was
like oh you know we need to get this
through so that we have this order but
that's already in statute the only thing
they changed about
the order of picking the surrogate is
removing the common law
um spouse so there already is you know
this
kind of hierarchy of who you know
is first chosen as the surrogate when
there's no advance directive
um but uh this still just doesn't
address
you know my a lot of my concerns still
haven't been addressed about
um you know in static
section i'm sorry
and on page 18 this is like another one
that i didn't get to before about lines
11 through 15 the issue applies to the
term burden
um the term bourbon is used but there's
no definition
and that's a subjective term so they're
saying you know stop
my my treatment or my tooth feeding or
this when i become so much of a burden i
think that the principles idea of a
burden and agents could be different
and it needs to be really clear and they
need to offer on the form
a way for them to make it very clear
exactly what
the parameters are for that burden
thank you representative representative
uh yes it doesn't say the patient being
a burden
it says the burden of treatment so what
we're speaking of here is
if that's again page 18 line
12. the burden of treatment may be that
it's simply something which
is not likely to give them any help and
will cause them a great deal of pain
or discomfort and we all know that
people make their own individual
decisions about
for example how much how far they want
to go with chemotherapy treatment and
when they have
almost no chance of improvement with
their fourth round and they're going to
be terribly sick they may choose
not to take that burden of treatment but
we're not speaking about the person
being a burden
we're speaking of the burden of
treatment so they put risks
and burdens because the risk may be
small but the burden as in the negative
aspect to their quality of life could
still be high
and that is why that person may choose
to not have the excessively burdensome
treatments
thank you representative is there anyone
else
thank you chairman i i would assert that
the uh
the fact that we are disagreeing right
now on
on so many of the the points in this
bill
is precisely the reason why it should be
retained
um not itled
nor otp'd but there are a number of
open questions that have come up during
this conversation
and retaining the bill i believe is the
most appropriate
next step to see that
whatever remaining concerns or
disagreements
or lack of clarity is
resolved so that this bill can move
forward
at some point after those questions have
been answered
but the fact that we're we're
questioning so much and disagreeing on
so much this is a relatively long bill
so there's a lot there there's a lot
there to question there's a lot there to
understand
and my concern is that if if we're
having this discussion in which we just
we're disagreeing on so much of what the
bill says and what it means
um that to me is is is a clear
thank you cushman representative
thank you mr chairman um just a couple
of final thoughts
um so we're having the discussion of the
proper
process to deal with this
understanding that some legislation that
it's likely that you know as we've seen
the governor has
dealt with things um unilaterally
that especially in the medical field um
and i don't see any reason why he
wouldn't be
forced to issue a new emergency order
about something like this um
yeah on the the other thing is uh
you know we need to this is not
something that should be rushed with a
floor amendment
um you know the next time we go meet in
the house could be
you know it's in the next month so i
think that this needs a little more
close examination um
you know open discussion and a real like
work groups
to get get it hammered out to what it
needs to be and that a four amendment to
fix these issues that we're seeing
would be too rushed and i think we need
to put it through a proper process of
work groups
to fix it thank you representative
we have two very long builds following
this one
so unless you have something new to say
i would suggest
we move to the vote however you have the
all right thank you mr chair i'll make
this really quick um
earlier i had no intention of of saying
that this
bill was being um classified as
euthanasia
from within this committee it as always
we've had a recent discussion
i agree with both sides i i think a lot
of the
the issues we have here
misunderstandings due to the complexity
of the bill
and and that's why i believe that we
should move forward and and vote against
retaining and carry on from there thank
you
anyone else the motion before us
is the motion to retain made by
representative gay
and seconded by representative cushman
if you choose to retain your vote is yes
if you do not wish to retain
your vote will be no the clerk may call
the rule
thank you and just a comment for
representative query i will add you to
uh
second to the last in the vote
uh representative marsh is absent
representative mcmahon
yes representative nelson
yes representative acton
no representative gay yes
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king yes representative
kobalt
yes representative weber
no representative mckay no
representative snow no representative
knurk
no representative soloway
no representative cannon no
representative nutter upham uh no
representative shapiro no
representative woods no
representative query no
representative pearson yes
sorry i have a another motion mr
chairman
um you have another motion uh please
hold off on that for just a second
here's got a little item he's got to
attend to here
um so the motion to retain has
failed and now we now we will entertain
another motion
and the chair calls on representative
webber
they move out to pass representative
weber moves on to to pass
i would like to second mr chairman and
that was representative soloway
i really don't expect there to be much
discussion at least i hope not
i need not speak to my motion mr
chairman anyway
emotion
no sir i said i did not need to speak to
my motion i think thank you very much
um
[Music]
a question of representative weber as a
parliamentarian
representative marsh has just entered
the room
um the motion is on the floor is he
eligible to vote
the question has not yet been put by the
chair so representative marsh is
available to vote
which is my thought but i wanted expert
opinion thank you very much
now the question before us on house bill
senate bill 74 is the motion of ought to
pass
as made by representative weber and
seconded by
representative soloway the uh clerk
please call the role thank you
representative marsh yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative nelson yes representative
acton
yes representative gay
no representative cushman now
yes i know i was having a hard time with
that
that answer representative kelsey
representative king no representative
cofoult
no representative weber
yes representative mckay yes
representative snow yes representative
knurk
yes representative soloway
yes representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative merchant
are you sure before knows
gay cushman oh five sorry i believe it's
16 to five
you're right i'm sorry thank you it
passes 16 to five
before we go on to the next bill
uh thank you for those who responded to
my
email about your preferences on
retained bills and a couple of you who
had previously emailed me and whose
email i lost
so i currently have responses from
representatives
woods soloway shapiro cushman
merchant marsh mckay snow
canark folsom cannon
others i would ask you to please get in
touch with me
as soon as you can because i would like
to
name groups to work on these bills
so at the call of whoever is that chair
of that
you can get started second item um
we passed 20 to one
out of this committee bill number 350
an act permitting qualified patients and
designated caregivers
to cultivate cannabis for therapeutic
use
and according to yesterday's new
hampshire sunday news kevin landrigan's
column
that bill was killed 15 to 9
in the senate um
which he entitles pot reform goes
proof so i'm surprised at that but i
just
if you didn't know i wanted you to get
uh representative
uh marsh would you write the board on
this place
[Music]
i will leave to the minority people to
decide amongst themselves who
will do that and just let me know
but um you know don't play rock scissors
paper without the hall thank you
that ends the exact session on the
senate
may i sir sir may i ask a question the
usual procedure is that the person who
makes the motion is the one who writes
the blurb unless they wish not to do so
should that not be offered to weber
first
it's entirely up ultimately i think it's
up to the chairman
and i certainly would be glad to defer
to representative marsh
okay yes and if if he needs any
assistance i'd be glad to offer it but i
leave it in his competent hands
thank you everyone um now to
open the hearing excuse me the executive
session on senate bill 149
and just to make sure that we've got all
of our papers
that we need to have there are
uh there is at least one amendment
this is not to move anything it's just
to make sure we've got
everything in hand uh i have
amendments uh 12 95
are there other amendments
on this bill for anyone's knowledge that
do we have one from do we have 14.90
from you
adam clarke
that's on 162. okay so the only
amendment we have is
1295 representative mr chairman i would
like to know that we
adopt uh one two
uh actually i have to really out of
order because i think we have to
move the bill first fine i'll move the
bill first and i know that we adopted
that
well okay uh we'll we'll accept the
first half and
call on you in a minute on the second
half
we do actually normally start with the
amendments don't we
even before we move the bill well yeah
because
if if there are amendments
on the house floor we do the bill first
and then the amendments but generally in
committee we do the amendments first and
then the bill
but whatever way you'd care to proceed
mr chairman at this point
we'll all take a deep breath and follow
along the chair calls on representative
marsh to um
move us around thank you mr chairman i
hope that we adopt
amendment 12958 to senate bill 149 and
i'll be glad
[Music]
uh all right amendment 1295-8
uh
[Music]
pharmacy already has the authority to do
now madame parliamentarian um do we
now vote on the amendment and then vote
on the bill
that's right okay so we have moved
and seconded moved by representative
marsh and seconded by representative
weber amendment 2021-1295
h on senate bill 149 fn
removing a a replacing section
replacing part two with what you see
before you
any further discussion before we
saying none with the clerk please call
the roll on the amendment
thank you representative marsh
yes representative mcmahon yes
representative nelson yes
representative acton yes
representative gay yes representative
cushman
yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey
yes representative king yes
representative yes representative weber
representative mckay yes representative
snow
yes representative knurk
yes my apologies representative soloway
yes representative cannon
[Music]
i think she she doesn't have her speaker
on rep i'll come back to her
representative nutter yes
representative woods yes
representative query
yes representative
pearson yes and
we'll come back representative cannon
[Music]
do you see a picture i see a picture
she's not responding
okay then comes up and wait tell her to
wait
no it appears to be frozen she may be
having hard frozen hardware
frozen
and if representative cannon i think
wants to add a
name to the list later on accept that
okay so we have 20 to zero
i don't think you can do that i don't
think she's present for
all purposes mr chair thank you okay but
i don't think it's going to change the
result at this point
we'll try and get hold of her now um
i'll entertain another motion to the
village the motion to the bill itself
chairman representative marsh i move
that
senate bill 149 on the path as amen
marshmallows has amended and who is
seconding
representative weber representative
marshall may speak
to your motion uh yes this uh bill does
three things it clarifies medicaid spend
down requirements
it allows the pharmacy to
[Music]
adopt automated pharmacy systems
long-term care facilities and las vegas
which will
say a significant amount of money and
holds health care facilities
harmless if they acted in accordance
with the epidural emergency orders
during the government epidemic i believe
all those provisions
are excellent ones this has
clearly been supported by the senate and
the congress
this is the chair speaking i noticed
maybe this
is overly fussy but on page two
line 35 which is the beginning of part 3
is the term copit19
and while covert 19 may eventually go
away
kobit 24 may show up or something
similar
it would be wise to have a floor
amendment
that would say covert 19
or an equivalent pandemic
or some word wording and i'm just
looking to the committee
to see what you think about that um
i think that this is a very narrowly uh
fashioned uh
section to do with what we specifically
had to deal with during
this year where we uh had to make
decisions
on short notice with limited information
and we're all doing the best we can and
start to broaden the scope
of that section of the law would not be
appropriate in the long term
and if a cover 24 should come up then
the legislature at the time can do it
my only question about that is here we
are
arguably 15 months into the pandemic
and we're now adopting this language
wouldn't it be good to have language
like this on the books
in month one of the next pandemic that
would be arguable and you could file a
bill like that
all right that's actually what i have in
any other discussion representative
cushman
thank you mr chairman i went back and
forth
on this bill uh specifically over this
section
being a registered nurse and
understanding that
um medical facilities were kind of under
the
the hammer of emergency orders and
you know had to comply but um
the medical ethics um
you know that's a pretty strong
um argument against this i think that
taking away
some responsibility for caring for
patients and making the right decisions
for patients that don't harm them
uh by giving them blanket immunity
for just going along with emergency
orders is
just bad practice i think that every
medical professional is responsible for
every decision that they make
and this would just you know quiet any
resistance any legitimate resistance
by medical professionals to an emergency
order because
they know that they're not liable so
that takes away a little incentive to
fight against it
um i i just think
that you know if there
it's determined that they acted in good
faith and
you know it should be determined on a
case-by-case business basis in a court
of law
if a family has a reason to believe that
some decision that these medical
facilities made
was responsible for some harm that came
to their family members
they have a right to bring that support
and have it determined by a judge
and that giving blank communities is not
the way to go about this and
you shouldn't just be like giving them a
free cover but
for you know decisions that potentially
could have been harmful whether there
was
an emergency order in place or not
yeah representative marsh yes thank you
this uh
section of the bill was drafted by a
threat based uh group of
stakeholders including the trial lawyers
association
i find it rather hard to believe that i
would be
uh finding myself in agreement with the
trial lawyers
association but i think that they were
very careful
to make sure that they did not
compromise the rights of individuals who
may
have actually suffered
[Music]
malpractice or some other event at the
hands of
medical professionals except for
uh the fact that mental knowledge may
have changed and it may have changed
dramatically over the last year
uh so i i think considering the number
of people input has gone into the
section it's very appropriate
but i i i'm afraid i would not apply
that to a broader scope as the chairman
has suggested please not without going
back to the state with this discussion
thank you representative anyone else for
the handoff
uh representative representative
thank you mr chair uh normally
i i'm not a big fan of omnibus bills but
seeing the situation we've been in with
with cove
we really had no choice i'd like to
thank dhhs for not sneaking in
any poison pills or any funny business
here that allows us to clean up
pass a clean bill um my only
the only issue i had was that we started
building an
omnibus uh amendment that where we
started putting all the
any issues into one big amendment and
that
takes away our ability to individually
address
the amendment so i hope in the future we
can move away from both
both practices but um and then finally
uh
you know the one issue i had is that
once again with with therapeutic
cannabis
these were department requested changes
um certainly very reasonable and and i
just i have a problem with the continued
um practice of of treating
patients and and atc's and people
involved in the program like we're
like we're gonna go out and if we're not
constrained by
um specific regulatory
burdens we're gonna go out and just uh
commit crimes left and right uh
there's a major felony for diversion
from the program
um the need to
keep these um tight uh production
controls on
on the atcs didn't really make sense to
me because
atcs are highly regulated they would
they would lose everything if there was
any
any diversion from from their level
so ultimately um put making
such an issue about the constraints on
on their production
i think unfairly um
cast an aspersion on them in a sense
where they
where we feel that we have to control
them we're also going to be selling it
out the back door to the black market
and there's no evidence of that at all
so i hope we don't do that
i think we're on the wrong bill that's
on 162.
representative i'm not
i am not calling on anyone
representation
i think you're speaking to the next bill
and not the president
right oh okay well um sorry about that
okay we'll remember what you said though
all right i i won't repeat it then uh
you guys know what i'm feeling here
sorry about that okay representative
snow
i have a question a very simple answer
for
i was a sponsor of a bill to upgrade
the threshold for
implementation of medicaid in and out
and there was some
change it was included in this around
the funding and i hope
it didn't impact the idea that that bill
which was passed
in the last session signed by the
governor to do it
be implemented as of joel june 30th of
there was some clarity about
whether money was going to be in the
budget or not in the budget it's going
to have to be paid for
on some other it doesn't have to be page
is there anything about
the change that is incorporated in this
bill i was told
that it doesn't impact the
implementation of that bill but i just
like reassurance
at this point if representative nash
commented
my understanding is that this does not
impact the implementation of that other
village
thank you representative
sorry about that the the first part of
the bill
which was inserted by uh senator
rosenwald
uh simply makes it exceedingly clear
that um um
now wait a minute i've lost it again uh
that that it it makes it clear
that um mental health expenses are
included
so it strengthens what we did before and
clarifies but it doesn't actually change
anything
the motion on the floor is on senate
bill 149
2021-1295 h
moved by representative marsh seconded
by representative weber
would the clerk please call the roll
thank you
representative marsh representative
mcmahon
yes representative nelson
yes representative acton
yes representative gay yes
representative cushman now
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
representative king yes representative
kobalt
no representative weber
yes representative mckay yes
representative snow yes representative
knurk
yes representative soloway yes
representative cannon i believe is still
absent representative matter up yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
query
[Music]
the vote is 18 yes two no
this ends the uh exec session senate
bill 149.
mr chairman is there a question of
consent or not
i i'm sorry repeat i have background
noise please
can the bill go on consent or is there
objection to consent
objections there is objection consent
thank you
i will let uh representatives cushman
and kobalt
flip a coin as to who gets to write a
i'm not going to do it okay
okay
mr mr chairman yes representative
could we take a five or ten minute break
well the chair was
very much considering that so i will
take that as a
i vote in secret uh okay the chair
unanimously uh declares that we will
take
could you let us know whether it is five
nice thank you thank you thank you thank
because it feels better than nothing
[Music]
there and come back next year and to fix
excuse me um health and human services
this is pam smarling upstairs i just
wanted you to know that your
the room is not muted if would you like
me to mute it
yes please please okay sorry about that
um but you just
you
hi this is pam smarling again just a
reminder to unmute the room when you're
ready to resume
and representative cannon can you hear
rented representative cannon seems to
have to be on here twice
[Laughter]
you only get to vote once
my backups went to my backup system and
and then everything was silent so i
thought both systems were broken
so pretty tricky representative kevin
yeah i'm having some tech problems today
too but i'm ready to switch to my iphone
at a
moment's i've got my chromebook next to
me but the
sound is terrible so okay
i am opening the exact session
on senate bill 162
when will they learn and the chair
recognizes representative
marsh to move an amendment yes thank you
[Music]
amendments 1402
h is there a second i second it
representative one of the sponsors of
any discussion representative marsh
speak to your motion
thank you this amendment does three
things first of all it clarifies
language in section 12 of the bill so
that canvas registry identification
cards do not
inadvertently uh become a license to
sell cigarettes
to use in the state of new hampshire
in its language which the department has
agreed to clarify that section just
make sure that consequence does not
happen
the second section of this amendment
deals with the fact that
section 48 of the bill as he received it
was incomplete
it only uh it was an amended delete
section to rsa 170
a and they only put in 178 colon one
and then put in language for eight two
three seven
so i'll work with the department to
complete that section of the bill
the last section of the bill adds
a requirement for evaluations for
children
the federal first prevention services
act uh this is the public requested
language
uh my understanding was that they
initially intended to
add this to house bill 120 as parallel
to language that's in my bill hospital
when 20 requiring
similar evaluations for children before
they're put on psychotropic medications
however the senate had already passed
that bill by the time
this language was forward and therefore
this was thought to be an
alternative for that the purpose is that
this
language is required to access titles
for e
funds uh for services dcyf intends to
provide and also will improve the care
of children placed in business
facilities
discussion
[Music]
this is uh discussion questions sharing
on
amendment 1402 h
by representative marsh and co-sponsored
by
representative connecticut and
seeing nothing
then the matter before us
is uh amendment 1402h
representatives
thank you representative marsh
yes representative mcmahon yes
representative nelson yes representative
acton yes representative gay
yes representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
yes representative king yes
representative kobalt yes
representative weber yes
representative mckay yes
representative snow yes
representative clerk yes
representative soloway yes
representative
cannon yes representative nutter upham
yes shapiro
yes representative woods
yes representative query
yes and representative pearson yes
and it passes 21 to zero 21 21-0
the chair recognizes representative
um this amendment is you have to
move it sorry yes um i i move
amendment 1490h
representative health
seconds now representative folsom to
your amendment please
um yes this this is the first amendment
um
that i brought forward because i was
being approached to
with regarding two major sections of the
cannabis
basically had quite a few problems and
those
two main problems that kept coming up
with people
were one the fact that
because we're eliminating the fact that
patients
have to be designated to an atc there
would be no
way to track those patients and how much
they're purchasing
at other ats possibly purchasing at
other atcs
for the total amount that they're
allowed each time
and the other major issue was the fact
that
now that there was uh no designation
every single qualifying patient
um was now every single person who had a
medical marijuana medical
cannabis card which meant
that um with seven atc's instead of
there being enough cannabis grown and
supported for 11
000 patients it would be the possibility
of enough cannabis being produced
and um
having the supply on hand for 77
000 uh people
and so those were the two
main things that i kept hearing over and
over again from people
the first part i really feel
that i believe that the
patients who use cannabis should be
allowed
to purchase it at any one of those atc's
i strongly believe that i believe that's
not an issue my issue is is that
they have put no place no uh
rules in place as to how to track it
just like you would track any other
medication in the state of new hampshire
i was told that it would be too
expensive
well the research i've been doing with
other growers
and providers the amount that
our new
atc our atcs charge
there would be more than enough money
to cover that cost and it would not be a
difficult cost
i can go into a home depot here in new
hampshire
and buy some paint for my bedroom
and if i wanted to
paint my friend's bedroom the same color
when i'm visiting her in colorado
i can go into a home depot there and go
oh what was the color of my paint
and how much did i need to buy to use do
that room
and lo and behold in about less than a
minute they could tell me
that amount so i do not believe
that um what
we're being told as being an exorbitant
expense
necessarily is one uh
the other thing about the uh the second
issue uh with regards to the amount
i was basically told that
why would the organizations
that have this cannabis and are
licensed want to grow more
than they would actually sell
and but yet they still want an increase
in the amount that they can
they have on hand uh because they would
have to destroy it
however i am not satisfied
with the whole management of the program
and i trust the patients inside and out
but on my own i'm going to start looking
at some of the companies
that are running the program and
and seeing if if the way they're running
them
are being run according to good
practices
and if they are i will congratulate them
and
if they're not this is one area where i
would be very comfortable limiting their
at that point uh so those those are my
two main points on this and i'd love to
hear what other people think
thank you representative any comments
representative gay
uh thank you for taking my question um i
thought that you had two two potential
amendments
is this the one that would uh allow them
to allow the atcs to
produce a lot more like three times as
much
[Music]
or is this the one that would maintain
their
current amount for the eight for the
people who are assigned to them
and as you think of the answer to that
uh i was surprised to learn that already
on the state website
uh where it lists all the atc's that
they're actually in pairs
and so currently any person who has a
card
to one of these pairs can go to each
either of the two or both excuse me
so which if you could clarify which
agreement this
is okay this amendment basically um
takes out the section which uh removes
the designation of atc
so in doing that the
they would the atcs would have to use
just their qualifying patients
as their multiplying factor with regards
to seeds and plants
and product the fact that
you see on the website uh that
you have some pairs that they can go to
i believe and i'm not 100 sure on this
but i believe that's because
out of the seven atc's there are only
four
um licensures so there's some
companies that own more than one and i
think they're using
a loophole to be able to pull that off
follow-up so this is the more
restrictive this is the more
this is this is more restrictive yes
uh representative mark i would like to
ask if we could have the opinion of the
department on this language and i also
would like to make a comment about the
word loophole it is my recollection that
you passed a specific bill i think
this last session that allowed the atcs
to have a second location so that was
not
right may i speak mr chair to answer
some of these questions too
a
uh representative folsom may answer
representative marsha's
statement okay i can tell you a little
bit about dhhs
has to say because i had conversations
with three people at ds
dhhs they are against
this amendment they feel
that the rights of the patient
which i even said right at the beginning
are very important
that um they uh
do not want that limited and therefore
we need to
do it for the patients but they do not
have any rules in place
to manage that system that's right they
have nothing
they don't even know the rules written
so that
that is what is happening there
and the reason why they initially
did not want any limitations on
the amount of cannabis that each center
could grow
was because some centers have
more patients than others
so one patient one center may need
to produce and have more
but with the qualifying patient still in
place
those those numbers still stay higher
for those atc's
i would like it if this was removed this
time
and we come back at another point
when the rules are in place when
the process in place for tracking and
uh where we're set to manage the amount
of cannabis
being produced and available
thank you representative the chair
recognizes representative penarch
thank you very much um just to clarify a
couple things first of all rules are
written after the legislation passes
because otherwise our
committee sorry our department should be
doing a lot of rules for no good reason
so sure there are not rules it's
important to understand that the whole
goal of allowing people to go to
different atc's
is to increase the choice the patient
freedom of choice
to go to the atc that they wish to for
two reasons basically
one is one atc may have a different
strain
with a certain cannabinoid profile and
terpenes
that works very well for that patient
but their designated atc
may not have it so they could go to a
different atc
and purchase that particular strain if
they wish to they can also change their
atc but they may
have a couple of different strains from
different places that they would like to
be able to get
first they're rather geographically
separated so it's not
real likely that people are going to run
all over the state
to be able to buy but it would just be
for that explicit reason
the second reason is to introduce a
little bit of competition here
a little bit of free market competition
because the therapeutic cannabis prices
are high
if you have some good competition
between different atc's
that may drive some traffic to one atc
preferably over the other
that was the reason to lift the caps was
to give the flexibility
so that if one atc becomes predominant
or begins to dominate a certain area
that they can grow more that they need
but it's really important to realize
that the atc atc's as far as a cap let's
just address that part part first
they're currently are not growing
anywhere near their maximum that they
can grow their
their plant counts are about six to 13
percent of what they're currently
allotted anyway
and the reason for that is they're
pretty well maxed out on their space
but there is no market for what they
grow except
their atc customers
they cannot sell it if they did they
would lose their license that means they
lose their business
it also happens to be a felony minor
couple of things there
so there is no market for any excess
cannabis and that has an expiration time
therefore it would just have to simply
be destroyed if they produce too much
that's not particularly good business
they can't export it anywhere they can't
sell it anywhere
only in their atc so the goal is to give
this
little bit of flexibility in terms of
shifting of the market because we don't
want to
allow take off take off the designated
atc
then suddenly have an atc that can't
produce enough because they become
if they're in the more southern part of
the state and people can can go to a
different place
suddenly they become much more popular
and they're getting a lot more business
and they can't grow what they need then
we have to come
back to the legislature so this was to
preempt that potential problem
that other focus is always on that
appearance or that problem that is
really not a real problem of people
buying cannabis at multiple atc's and
then
reselling it if they don't have a
designated they can go anywhere and be
tracked first of all
we do not track other medications except
opioids
and we do track pseudoephedrine because
it's a building block for
methamphetamine
otherwise your prescriptions are not
tracked they are by the company
but they're not tracked by the state so
the he the key is that if people want to
run around and buy
stuff they are it's a real problem
because it's illegal already for them to
purchase more than a certain amount in a
given time frame
to possess more than a certain amount or
to divert cannabis to any other
person violation of that leads to loss
of their card
and criminal penalties their felonies
second it doesn't make really good
business sense to buy therapeutic
cannabis and sell it in the black market
because their atc cannabis is much more
expensive than black market cannabis is
as a result you'd be buying expensive
cannabis to sell it at a loss i don't
think very many people are going to want
to do that
and lastly as far as tracking currently
in this state any person who has a new
hampshire card can go across the border
to maine
massachusetts vermont and canada and buy
cannabis legally
they're they're still violating the law
in terms of possessing too much and so
on
they also break another law by crossing
a border either state or international
with cannabis but these people it's not
tracked if somebody really wanted to
circumvent this
they can do it now by just going to a
neighboring state and purchasing
legal recreational cannabis um
i think i'll let dennis acton go back
and give his little comment but
you got to realize most of these people
the the major major age of the people on
therapeutic cannabis program
are 50 and 60 the most common indication
being
pain you know it's this is not reefer
madness
these are people using therapeutic
cannabis reliably and responsibly
and we're just simply trying to improve
the patient
uh experience to be able to go have some
competition as far as which atc they go
to
both for the brand that the the variety
they want
and preferably maybe drive the price
down
so that's i this this amendment is
really i think
not needed uh and would
hurt some of the reforms you're trying
to put into the program thank you
representative acton shapiro
representative acton
uh thank you mr chair so i made my point
last time
that was embarrassing sorry i got a
little ahead of myself here but you guys
know what i was trying to get at
uh originally the the amendments were
starting to pile up into the into one
amendment i i
voiced my concern over that issue uh
that we should deal with these things
separately and that and that was done so
um and and uh representative conrad made
made the point that that i was going to
make as well so um
i just you know after the the final
testimony that came in in the hearing
from the police chief uh really that
hurt that was painful
to yet again have patients
being treated like criminals just to
boil it down to a to something we made
you know i've been i've been a patient
advocate for this for 14
years now and we still are
considered and you know 350 got killed
it's it's just one thing after another
and i really wish people would stop
trying to um make it like we're all just
waiting to
break the law if given even the
slightest
chance so um thank you thank you though
for uh hearing me up
thank you representative representative
shapiro
i'm going to pass thank you thank you
anyone else with a hand up on your
screen
2021-1498
to the senate bill 162 fm moved by
representative folsom seconded by
representative kelsey
would the chair please call the roll um
the clerk would be glad to call the roll
um
marsh no representative mcmahon
no representative nelson
no representative acton
no representative gay yes
representative cushman no representative
folsom yes representative kelsey
representative king no representative
cofoul
i do not see oh i can't see his face
because he's
off screen representative weber no
representative mckay no representative
snow
no representative clerk
[Music]
no thank you representative soloway
no representative cannon no
representative francis nutteruppum no
representative shapiro no
representative woods no
representative cleary no representative
pearson
now
are you able to hear me now um i can
hear you but i have to see your face
yeah i i've been i keep getting kicked
off of the meeting
it's happened about six times in the
past half hour so i'm having some
connectivity
issues i think i can connect now
we'll hold it open for a minute so
my vote my vote was was no on this one
okay
i see that three to 18. um yes so the
motion is defeated
three yes and 18
no representative folsom would you like
to
move another amendment yes i would like
to move amendment
1497 and
is there a second representative gay
seconds representative folsom please
speak to your
second uh amendment okay this amendment
is a compromise amendment i worked out
with michael holtz
over the weekend uh michael holt i'm
sorry michael holt is the person who
runs the
medical cannabis program for the state
okay
um we went back and forth with many of
the same arguments that
we just shared regarding the last
amendment
i had just promised quite a few people i
would bring that amendment forward
so i did this one is a
much larger compromise on my part
and on the part of some other people
what this does is it does not remove the
designation
so people can go to any one of those
sites and i will be working
probably looking at to find some way to
track that
like we do opioids but that's not part
of this amendment but that's my goal
coming out of this so patients will
still be able to go to any one of those
sites
we also talked about the fact that we
did we really need
an increase in the amount of cannabis
that was being grown
[Music]
now um what we did is we reached
a compromise so instead of using the
full
figure of the number of can of
qualifying patients now which is
a 11 000 plus a few
uh we are limiting it to 25
of the total number of qualifying
patients
so it brings so any one of those sites
so but we're talking about the
multiplying figure
that goes that is used against number of
seeds the number of plants the amount of
product
so instead of using the whole 11 000
total they only get to use 25
of that what that does is it helps cover
the atc's who have a larger
clientele pool because they're in the
cities
um that and that helped cover the fact
that they are going to need more
than necessarily uh the atc's in the
other part of the state that may not
any further discussion or questions of
the
uh amendment writer representative marsh
yes thank you mr chair uh we heard that
this amendment is a compromise with
michael foley of dhhs i see that michael
holt
has his hand up as an attendee and could
we please hear from the department of
so let me hear their side of this
discussion the chair recognizes michael
uh hello thank you mr chair members of
the committee my name is michael holt
i'm the administrator for the
therapeutic cannabis program
how may i help you your name has been
cited as
uh one that the mover of this amendment
consulted
on amendment 1497h
that is true we would like you to say
whatever you wish to say to
uh thank you i spoke with representative
folsom last week
about amendment um 1497.
um the uh the compromise
that she refers to is a compromise based
on
you know this is where our conversation
ended um
a 25 cap on
uh on on a plant count limit
um i believe is unnecessary due to
the testimony provided by representative
knurk earlier
in that none of the atc's are anywhere
close to their current
cap um however a 25
cap does not pose a particular problem
to the department or the atc's
um like i said it's unnecessary but it
it will not be it will not limit
their ability to serve the patients of
new hampshire the
only outlier concern that i would have
is that if every patient decided to go
to the same
atc and not utilize the other one that
single atc would not have
the uh sufficient uh quantity of plants
and cannabis to be used
um however i do think that's an unlikely
scenario uh currently there are
approximately 12
000 patients in the state four atc's
with three operators there are only
three cannabis
operators in the state um this bill
would
split them up based on license 25 per
license
although there are only three operators
so um it doesn't pose any particular
harm but in my view it is unnecessary
thank you mr holt would you please stay
in the meeting in case there are
questions
yourself representative um marsh
yes thank you mr holt and thank you for
taking my question
uh you said that there are three growers
in this state
and we are tapping each of the three
it's 25 percent of the qualifying
patients
and that's not 100 so could you clarify
there are four atc licenses
one operator has two of those licenses
under the proposed amendment each
license
would be capped at 25 which means
that one of the atc's the one that holds
two licenses would be capped at fifty
percent
that's how you get to a hundred percent
follow up one one more follow-up and
this will be one last
one uh so if we're growing exactly 100
of the qualified patients is there any
uh adjustment allowed if one atc
happens to have more patients than the
others because
it seems to me that if there's any uh
inequality in the
distribution of patients someone's gonna
run out of hands
under this bill there are no designated
atc's
uh so there are no they're no longer any
we don't know
who is going to go where um
currently uh there is a range of
you know from about 1200 patients for
the lowest atc
to about 4500
patients to the atc that has the most
patients
um so so we don't we don't really know
the answer to that i think it is
possible but very
unlikely that um the most popular atc
the atc that uh does the best at uh
um the friendly competition that
representative canark was saying
yeah it's possible that they would uh
they would get closer to their maximums
um the the data that i have shows that
you know the the maximum is up to 70
percent under a 25
cap i can't imagine it um
it going again i can't imagine there
being a problem with the 20
cap here because patients will continue
to go to all the atc's in the state
thank you my questions denise anyone
else
with the question for mr holt or comment
about the
proposed amendment i have a comment
representative gay had her hand up
emotionally before yours
so representative this
is an overall kind of view that my
my concern is not with allowing more
people to go
so i'm not against this bill
what my concern is that we are
we're i think most of us our concern is
for the patients
that we want to make sure they have
access to
these uh to the right kind of cannabis
for them
my concern is that as more and more
bills come
it's that cannabis across the country
is a big growing concern that's making
some people
very wealthy it's not just we know about
big tobacco
we know about big pharma well this is a
big
a big enterprise too and i would like us
to have
some more thought for future reference
about not allowing it to take over
as tobacco and pharmaceuticals did
i'd rather put the skids on now instead
of oh my gosh we have a problem
what do we do now so that that is so
that is my concern it's not this bill
it's
as this bill expands in the future
thank you representative representative
thank you just one thing to i did
something to say but i wanted to go back
to what
to clarify a bit what i what i think mr
holt was saying earlier too
that issue is that under the
under the bill without this amendment
there would be the flexibility to be
able to allow one atc to produce
more if they needed to because they had
more patients
with this amendment we have the 25
percent cap
currently they could probably increase a
fair amount as
mr holt points out you'd have to have
one become extremely dominant before
they would then
run out but the important thing is
currently there are designated centers
if we take away the designated atc
but we pass this amendment there is the
chance of having one predominant atc who
does a good job
unable to produce their amount that they
need without this amendment we don't
have that which is why i think this
is still an unnecessary amendment
because
again i already said all my other
comments
they're not growing more than they can
sell there's no market for it they have
to just destroy it that's not good
business
so they're not going to do that but this
gets us in statute the flexibility
to be ready if things do change what i
wanted to say earlier is
somebody earlier made a comment about
comparing cannabis to opioids
it really is a very different thing in
the last 20 years about 500 000 people
have died of opioid overdose
and you can probably count on your hands
and toes the number of people that died
of a true cannabis
overdose and the reason for that is very
clear there are no cannabinoid receptors
in the portion of the brain that
controls respiration
but there are opioid receptors that's
how you get killed
yes there are problems potentially with
driving under the influence as there is
with
opioids with alcohol and with not enough
sleep
but we also don't think that that
there's no good evidence that's a major
problem
either so again to clarify this is
not as deadly as cannabinoids it doesn't
need that kind of
solid tracking and if we want to have
tracking we could probably
still try to put that in but we would
have to appropriate some money
to the program to do that um i it's
they're not awash in money to be able to
put in a tracking system
at this point in time that would be a
bill for another day if we wish to
so in essence i echo what mr holt said
it's this we can live with this although
there is a potential
for one atc perhaps to get into trouble
with not being able to produce enough
and needing to come to legislature to
change it but i think it's unnecessary
thank you thank you representative
anyone
else representative woods
thank you mr chair and um uh thank you
mr holt uh for uh taking my question i
have a couple
um my understanding uh that
uh if one etc uh license
uh runs short of a product uh
a different atc uh has an excess
uh they're allowed to sell at whatever
wholesale price uh they can sell to the
other atc is that correct
thank you for the question
representative woods that is correct
current law does
allow sale between the new hampshire
atc's
good thank you you may or may not have
the um uh amendment in front of you
uh but on line seven uh item
uh parentheses one uh and then line
nine parentheses two seem to be at odds
it says in the first line uh that um
what can be grown um but
they're very different and the
quantities would be very different
um i i need some help understanding
uh the difference between the the two
thank you representative woods uh i
don't disagree
that uh this section of the existing law
is not
a model of clarity um this uh this
provision has gotten um
some uh attention or uh i believe it was
a
the result of a compromise when the bill
was drafted
um and it has never been um completely
or has never been addressed the lack of
clarity
what the department i can i can explain
what the department
interprets number one to mean is that
that is an excess amount so being the
standard amount
three plants 12 seedlings six ounces for
each patient who's
designated that particular atc in our
rules
we explain that paragraph one 80
cannabis plants 160 seedlings and
another 80 ounces is an extra amount
to deal with failed crops uh sale
to other atc's and for start-up costs
so no and and because these two
paragraphs are connected by an and
they would be added so in addition to
the per patient amount in two
the atcs are also allowed to possess
this number of extra plants that are
unrelated
to per patient
so if i understand correctly the way the
rest of the bill
i'm sorry follow-up mr chair
um so if my understanding is correct
then would the
term on line eight qualifying patient in
uh uh parentheses one does that mean
per atc or the way we've written the
rest of it would that be
qualifying patients registered under
this chapter
we have written our rules essentially
um to disregard that clause or six
ounces of usable cannabis per qualifying
patient
because it's redundant with the paragra
the the provision in two
so our rules establish the 80 plants
160 seedlings and 80 ounces of usable
cannabis
full stop okay so basically
we could strike lines seven and eight um
and that would help clarify you could
strike
line seven and eight starting with the
comma before the word
or and that would remove the confusion
and the current law
representative folsom um
when you're looking at lines seven and
eight and then followed with um
the two in parentheses what is
interesting
is the very last word on uh set on line
eight is the word and so technically by
law it's an and even though the rules
have been written as just
the portion under number two
no and the fact yeah and so
one of the things that um with regards
to
making sure that and att atc does not
run out is one the ability to
uh have a transaction between atcs
and then also the fact that um
most it has been explained to me um
that most people will probably stay at
their same atc
so there won't be a huge shift in
in what's going on and
the 25 still gives them plenty of room
uh but it just helps put like
representative gay said puts the skids
on a little bit
just to kind of this this whole medical
cannabis program
was built or not built but promoted
to be a program that was going to be
tightly run and so
when it was passed and so i i'd like to
anyone else representative mccann thank
you mr chairman
i've spent years as chairman of the
medical marijuana commission one of the
major
concerns has always been access
to the marijuana
there's always been conflict
particularly chief of police has been
voted
as a standing position that is held for
five years
lost so that comes as
absolutely no support
my concern is anything that
interferes with the individual's access
to those individuals who are qualified
[Music]
so i don't think that this
amendment helps i think what it does is
makes access
[Music]
thank you representative
is there another hand up on the screen
uh yes shapiro representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman and um this
question might have been answered in
part
um with the response to representative
woods
um question but um
mr holt i understand from what you're
saying that while
you don't think this is necessary that
it's very unlikely that atcs would run
out of products
but i'm wondering if this 25 limit
would constrain the choice of products
at any
given atc if it would um limit or
constrain the um strains that
maybe become uh popular because they're
more effective
at any particular atc or is that not an
issue
thank you for the question
representative shapiro i i honestly
don't know
um the the atcs have not had an
opportunity to
to weigh in on this this cap um i don't
like i said at the beginning i don't
think this is a huge problem
um to pass this amendment um i think
it's unnecessary
i think the concerns are you know
largely unfounded
um but uh it may have downstream
consequences that we're not aware of
atc's are able to sell to one another so
if one got in a real pinch
then you know presumably a certain
strain could be
you know backfilled by another atc if
that of second atc
sold that strain or produced the same
products
um but at that point well the patient
could go to the other atc
you know i mean all their formulations
are slightly different they all
sell flour they all sell tincture they
all sell vape cartridges
but the variety um um
different you know the the the strains
they differentiate between the atcs
i think the answer is we don't know i
don't know the answer to that question
um i think there's a possibility of
downstream impacts that we can't quite
envision
at this time but i'd rather this bill
get passed
thank you i think i see representative
weber
thank you mr chairman i would like to
say that
uh yes historically this bill has been
very
tightly controlled and even
with the loosening of controls that we
see in this bill
i think we still have a pretty good
handle on
what's going on and of course the
difference is
that now we have a track record and
the issues that have come up have
been on the part of patients
not being able to get what they need
they've been issues of access they've
been issues of price
they've been issues of being able to get
the right product that you need for your
condition
and i think that this bill as it was
originally drafted helps with all of
those i'm particularly
uh pleased with the aspect of
competition that
might actually drive some pretty
expensive prices down a little bit
and finally i just want a second
two of the points that representative
acton made
earlier one being that
we are talking patients here and
patients should not be
uh subject to the kinds of
hoops to get something that will treat
them
and and and so i'm for removal of hoops
for patients rather than
increasing or or having the possibility
of increasing hoops for patient
on the one hand and on the second thing
and just
this is just globally not this amendment
i also
second what representative acton said
about not being a fan of omnibus bills
and being very appreciative of having
the amendments be offered one by one so
we can vote on them individually
so i thank people for that thank you
very much mr chair and members
thank you representative representative
folsom
okay i'll just thank you so much to the
rest of the committee
for allowing this freshman legislator to
come out here on such a simple issue
um and get her feet wet
um and i just have a couple little
comments
um just to respond to some other
people's comments
and that is one if we're worried about
uh atcs not having particular strange
strains because they become more popular
um
it's a good business model that if uh
you have a string that's becoming more
popular you're
gonna start carrying more of that
product
and the competition issue
i'm having some problem with because of
the fact
that you have the same group owning
a multiple well license for multiple
sites
so if one company owns or we're limiting
the number of companies
that own these uh atc's
there's not a lot of incentive to drop
their prices
but and thank you very much for
for helping me walk through this
amendment and
um it's been an incredible learning
experience
representative
yeah i'm you i i just muted myself yeah
i just wanted to ask
i think mike holt kind of gave us soto
voce
no at one point about still that
confusion of line seven
eight and nine when representing folsom
was earlier speaking
and i was hoping he would address that
could he
i i think there was still some confusion
about the fact that it was one set of
data
and that the rules still had allowed
both one and two
it just took out the six ounces of
usable cannabis because that was
thank you representative knurk yes um
your uh your summary is correct
um in our rules we have the same
structure as in the statute
in that it is an and there are two
categories
we establish the primary category as the
per patient amount
in um that's in paragraph two we go on
to say
and up to eight up to an additional 80
mature plants
160 seedlings and 80 ounces of usable
cannabis
including for start-up operations to
assist with a failed batch of cannabis
to allow sufficient quantity of cannabis
for new patients
or to fill requests for the sale of
cannabis to other atc's
in our rules we have not included the
confusing language
yeah just a quick follow-up the other
thing in terms of the strains and
competition indeed
i think we will see that we in statute
this was set up with four atc's we
expanded to some other areas because
there were markedly underserved areas
particularly
the north country and down in the
southwest and that's why some atc's have
more than one
actual sales front uh to be but we in
statute it's only set at four
and we'd have to change that and we have
not done so
as far as a strain it does take some
time to start growing another strain
it's a biological
sorry it's a botanical product and if
you say wow this is really going to be
good
you have to ramp up production and it's
going to be a significant amount of time
so it isn't
a simple switch turn there's no supply
chain going elsewhere
but indeed it is expected that we would
see
uh the atc's respond to the demand that
would be the hope
representative gay
one of my concerns that again
is it's not exactly in this bill but one
of my concerns is that we're speaking it
as if people want it so we don't need
any kind of controls
the pharmaceutical industry from
the personal point of view not the
industry but me and that purchaser
i have to i have to be bound by
controls so i don't want to
i don't want to go totally like
we don't need controls because if we
didn't need controls why do we have them
on pharmaceuticals
if i want a painkiller i can't just go
to the nearby
store and show my card and buy as much
as i want
are even the limit on what it wants you
know it's supposed to be
tailored to what i should have uh so i'm
i am concerned about treating
marijuana medical marijuana therapeutic
marijuana
which i do think is a good thing i'm
just
a little concerned about the laissez
faire a field slasic fair
about this as opposed to a
pharmaceutical
i'd be happy if the federal government
didn't keep acting like marijuana was
totally illegal
so that everybody has to be bound by
their rules
if it was treated as a pharmaceutical
and
the different mixes were in hill form
and it was a controlled a controlled
thing because you can say
oh it's not a hard drug it doesn't
affect the brain but we know for a fact
that lots of people
are addicted to it in addition to a
zillion other things in new hampshire
which is this
severe problem that we temporarily
forgot the dealing with codeine
so i would really like people to get
their mindset to combine
the way you treat pharmaceuticals and
the way you treat
the therapeutic uh canvas
it shouldn't be two separate ways to
deal
we really need to be put the same
controls
on anything that's affecting the mind or
the body
look with the same care that we
do to uh pharmaceuticals
thank you representative
um we do not have anything in statute
that limits
how much product uh pharmaceuticals can
make i don't think that there's any
limit
on how many uh the senate pro pills the
producer
can make and we also don't limit uh
where they can
sell them this is extremely tightly
regulated
in our state program and it is not
a laissez-faire program so i if we're
going to make comparison to
pharmaceuticals
we would throw out a lot of the
restrictions we currently have in the
therapeutic cannabis program
also though the rate of actual addiction
in cannabis
is not everybody it's i i'm quite sure
it's around 12 percent
i think is the current number who
actually do have cannabis use disorder
but that's primarily
in recreational patients do you
understand again as i've said before in
therapeutic cannabis
we start with a low dose we slowly
titrate to get the therapeutic effect
while avoiding the unwanted effects of
euphoria
and mental disruption because that is
not the intended effect that is a side
effect
and so we do not see with the cannabis
use disorder rate in therapeutic
cannabis
is probably markedly smaller we do not
have that data
that is markedly different than the
i do not mean controlling the
pharmaceutical anymore
i meant i am controlled by what i can
get
at the pharmacy so i wouldn't make a
comparison
i'm in control i can't just take a card
it says i'm gonna try over this much and
just go
multiple places and get it the control
is on the patient
so i didn't mean to make a
foolish comparison of the suppliers
of pharmaceuticals and the suppliers of
uh although that's how we try to control
it in the state
we try to control who dispenses
and we definitely need to change the law
so that we don't have
four people controlling the whole you
know
state
like to get to a roll call on this if
anyone has anything that we haven't
heard
and really needs to say it
i don't see anyone
the motion before us is amendment 1497
h to senate bill 162
fn moved by representative folsom
seconded by representative gay would the
clerk please
call the world thank you representative
marsh
yes representative mcmahon
[Music]
yes representative cushman now
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
yes representative king yes
representative no
no representative mckay
no representative snow no
representative knight no
representative soloway no
representative cannon no
representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro no
representative woods no
representative query no
representative pearson yes
fifteen seven no i'm sorry
fourteen seven seven in favor fourteen
opposed the motion fails uh
i do not see before me any further
amendments if anyone does please let me
now before us is senate bill 162
2021-1402
the chair will entertain a motion on
this bill
representative marsh mr chairman i move
that that senate bill 162
as amended by uh amendment 1402 h
on defense representative marsh moves
ought to pass do we have a second
second miracle second that is ought to
pass
as amended seconds
a lot of people are thinking about it
the chair would like to just
comment on section 59 coverage plan for
services to individuals
with developmental disabilities as a
group
that i spent some time working with two
of the area agencies on
there has been an age gap 18 to 21.
it's nice to see that that is somewhat
being addressed in here
that's all i have to say
uh that is on page 31 and actually uh
i'd like to actually i would like to
continue that the department of health
and health
incorporate in its appropriation request
the cost of fully funding services
to eligible persons this is the
weightless thing this is something i was
very
happy that representative weiler chair
of finance
allowed me to grill him for several
minutes lobbying on this behalf
anybody else representative folsom um
yes thank you
mr chair i just want to say before we
vote that there are incredible great
things in this bill that need to go
through so
even though the things that i don't like
about it are stuck in there
i am in support of the bill thank you
representative pushman
thank you mr chairman um so i
going back to section 59 what
part of statute because i have asked
melissa saint ceo to clarify because
um i was confused on
why the um the fiscal note had
you know zeros across for the impact of
this section
if it's saying that it's providing
funding for but
um st sear
uh clarified that section 59
only requires the department to work on
a plan
and i had played with changing the
language to say
you know shall provide a plan for
develop a plan
post action plan something um and i was
waiting to hear back from her
on what statue
section 59 comments or changes
or where in statute the language is
so
i'm looking at the side by side that
christina daya provided
us with with the senate bill on the left
side and note senate on the right
and the notes read that
this section 59 designates
collaboration with dhs doa drc of new
hampshire
and the 10 area agencies
that's all it says okay so but we don't
john williams is on the call well thank
you
thank you very much uh yes
and i have to unmute so thank you very
much um
that will end up in what they call
session law or chapter law it's not
related to a specific
rsa but it carries a full force as if it
were in an rsa
i got the knowing not an approval of
representative weber so i have a
double confirmation that that is
absolutely
just just as a further clarification
uh session law doesn't get published in
the books
it usually gets used for a freestanding
thing like this
which is expected to be done in
a certain amount of time which this is
and as as mr williams said it it's
it's it's a mandate it's law but we
don't
put it into the session into the actual
statute books because it's one of those
things that
simply happens among a group of people
and it gets done and our researchers and
various
other people do actually pull their hair
out
tracking these things because they
do get tracked they do not get forgotten
and
uh people in the speaker's office also
but this is just a freestanding mandate
to
a group of people to get together and
form a plan
so there isn't going to be a permanent
home for it in the statutes
because we hope that they will get
together and form a plan
and that will be presented to us at a
further legislative session for our
action
representative weber with the fact that
it has a sunset provision this year
be another reason why it would not go
into
the logbooks exactly thank you
any other comments questions
can i just give representative cushman
the eagle eye award for noting that
though that's
that was very good thank you one eagle
eye
award has been bestowed
someone else okay eagle eye cushman is
recognized
thank you mr chairman so i
i do just have a bit of an issue i
we discussed this um
this interstate compact a bit about
the placement of children and there was
some debate
on whether it becomes a federal program
if we
join it and then we lose our autonomy
over it
um and i know that representative folsom
tried to reach out to multiple
organizations who are involved in this
and didn't receive any um feedback
didn't receive any calls back
um or email so i'm uncomfortable i think
that this
this part of the bill just totally
is like doesn't fit in with everything
else that this
bill does um and it's like
couched in the middle of the bill and
it's the major portion of the bill the
interesting
yeah so i'm just not comfortable with
this section of the bill at all and i
will
be voting in favor
the side by side notes provided by
christina daya read this way about this
compact
this is the 2009
interstate compact for the placement of
children
persian which replaces the current
version
but is not in effect until passage by 35
states that's what i'm reading
refiling of 2020 senate bill 698
at the request of dhhs this died on the
table
in the house
for what that's worth representative
snow
no i didn't mr representative um
thank you mr chair i spent some time
working on section 48 as you know
the amendment that we adopted did
incorporate
some new provisions into section 48. uh
the state of new hampshire has been part
of the state compact replacement
children since 1965
however the compact has been updated and
the purpose of this section of the bill
is to update
the current contact with the new compact
once enough states have adopted the new
compact that it becomes
operational so in fact joel this does
not
change the fact that we've been part of
this compact for
that's 35 years uh without any harms to
the state of new hampshire
in fact it allows us to do things like
have adoptions across the appliances
things like that
and therefore i very much support the
section of the bill i think it's
important for us to
to keep up to date as this contract
has been updated to reflect to
[Music]
or anyone else happen to know how many
states have thus far
ratified this language uh what i do know
is that it's unlikely that it will meet
the 35 state threshold
this year but of course that's not
necessary
[Music]
representative weber has your hand up
thank you i'm not getting much answer
here
representative weber representative
weber had her hand up what was
muted so um that's why
uh and thank you i i just want to make
it very
clear i want to second everything that
representative marsh said but i also
want to make it very clear this does not
become
federal law all that ever happens with
us
is what we as a legislature have adopted
and there's a further caveat
that until 34 other legislatures
also adopt similar measures it
won't go into effect more broadly but
when it goes into effect it will only go
into effect
for those states that have actually
adopted the update
um and and some of the other provisions
that would be
very helpful that are in this is it will
make it much
easier for a child in need of foster
care
to go into a relative placement
say in the state of maine or the state
of vermont or the state of massachusetts
uh so that we can keep families as
intact as possible
when a child is in need of foster care
rather than having to take that child
and put it into a foster family
in new hampshire and
it also allows us to track that child
and make sure that that child is being
dealt with appropriately when they're
not physically in the state
so i i think it's very useful
going forward and it is just an update
of something that's been in place for
about
for decades thank you representative
weber the chair has a question for you
or
indeed anyone who may know the answer
where does the number 35
come from who says it has to be 35.
it's it's contained in the bill
somewhere
and um i
don't i will continue to look at it but
ah it's on the top of page 11
um on the effective date of this chapter
based upon the enactment of the
interstate compact for the placement of
children into law by the 35th compacting
state
the governor is authorized and directed
to execute a compact
on behalf of this state with any other
state or states legally joining so
once the 35th ratification comes through
then the governor
can uh execute the paperwork
back and forth that i understood
what i wonder is who says 35 did some
state start with the bill it's
quite common when you have one of these
interstate
compacts that somebody comes
up with a threshold number i'm
remembering the last
time we saw a threshold number
like that was when we passed the sipe
act
which was an interstate compact
on allowing psychologists
to um practice across state lines
and i don't remember what the threshold
in that was
but there was one and
um i think it was a much lower threshold
actually
but again these are a matter of
negotiation among states and among the
drafters in the various states
i know that for many of our uniform laws
there's
actually an interstate commission
on uniform laws like
the uniform probate code or the uniform
commercial code
each state sends delegates they work out
a new version and then each state does
with the new version what the state
wants to do
so um the it's it's very
much a collaborative effort but without
the buy-in from individual states it
doesn't happen
well somebody started at one point there
was a similar thing with radiologists
that i've been meeting
the issue is it's just two-thirds of the
number of states that's probably why it
representative folsom thank you mr chair
and um i am so glad representative weber
is with us today because i've got a
question for you
it's a legal question and um it's one of
the ones that i have to go online and
look up because i couldn't get anybody
to answer for me
interstate compacts um
i tried to find the answer to this
question
because uh the way i read it online
is when an interstate compact
is in effect and a state is part of it
if the federal government creates rules
or laws
that differ from those of the individual
states
that the federal law trumps the state
law is that
well that if if the interstate compact
and because it's an interstate compact
it's it's something that the federal
government
also has some jurisdiction over it
if the federal government decides to
enact a law that conflicts
in the same area that law would in fact
control unless somebody successfully
brings a lawsuit and says
federal government this was not
something that was delegated to the feds
this is something that was reserved to
the states um
certainly the the care
of children is something that is
reserved
generally speaking to the individual
states
so i'm not sure
and and i'm not a constitutional scholar
and i'm a long
retired attorney so um i'm not
sure how a challenge to this would be
received if they enacted something in
this area
but whether we adopt a compact or
whether we don't adopt a compact
there they can do what they want to do
anyway and again it's
it's up to people in individual states
who are affected
to bring a challenge to whether they
exceeded their federal authority or not
and that
that wouldn't be changed whether we
adopt this compact or whether we reject
it
thank you very much i i was thinking the
same thoughts but i needed a lawyer to
say that
that
this is not just for questions this is
an exact session
so it can be sharing a statement
representative gay has called for thank
you for allowing me to ask
uh this probably really is for our
representative
can other states is there a list of 35
who've already been
uh sharing this responsibility or is
this just a number
in any state could choose to join
there is undoubtedly somewhere a list of
those who have adopted it already
i don't happen to have that list it
would be a great question
to ask ms dyer or the folks at ols who
do research for individual
representatives
uh i i don't um it it certainly
has already been passed by the threshold
number of states
in some of its earlier versions because
we operate with it now we we already had
it in law
and what we have currently in law is
cumbersome and clunky
and of course because they repealed the
whole thing and didn't
do the usual thing that we have with
line out and replacements
you don't see that but
this simply allows um
more more cooperation and and
more reaction to the currents
the current issues than than something
that's
significantly older less clunky
what's clunky um this is the chair it's
interesting to me that what is before us
is the 2009
version it's just 12 years old and like
some amendments to the constitution that
have been proposed
we haven't got to the threshold yet
we're 12 years late
into the game and we haven't hit the
magical 35.
just a comment just an observation uh
representative folsom
um just for information the interstate
compact uh for the placement children
has a website
so you can find out a whole bunch about
it online
very easy to find just not the rules
representative
thank you mr chairman so one of my
concerns
and correct me if i'm wrong someone who
may know better
um except on page 16
of the bill we're in section 4
and it's roman rule 7.
it says nothing in this article shall
limit the receiving state's ability to
take emergency jurisdiction for the
it at first it says in the uh the
beginning of that section you know
accepted
as provided in article seven um
sorry as provided in articles
for paragraph eight and
five that
the original state you know has
jurisdiction over this child
but then it says that the state that
they the child gets sent
to um the receiving state
has the ability to take over
jurisdiction of that child
so that's really concerning to me so if
they go to another state and they have
different
child protection laws um and they're
with their relative
and now all of a sudden that state
takes jurisdiction of the child and
places it someone else
representative weber i believe that what
this
does is that it allows another state if
a child is found
wandering on the street with no shoes to
take immediate jurisdiction over
that child and make take immediate
prevent
prevent measures for the protection of
the child it's truly an emergency
provision it does
not because
otherwise if we didn't have that savings
clause
uh a child wandering around on the
street unsupervised
they would have to try and figure out
where the original state was they
wouldn't know
because the child might be young enough
not to be able to tell them
so it's simply my understanding of
provisions like this
is it simply allows an emergency action
to be taken
to make sure that a child who's in
jeopardy either from
another person or because they've gotten
lost or
whatever has happened to the child
and and look after the child while
they're making the inquiries about the
proper jurisdiction for looking after
the child
and the proper communications that are
set out in the rest of the statute
but it's only in an emergency this is
the chair speaking
since i do not have in front of me
the version that is currently operative
in new hampshire
which predates the 2009 version which is
before us
i have no way of knowing if such
emergency jurisdictions
are already operative in new hampshire a
lot of this stuff i'm sure
isn't original it's updated it's some
change
made here and there but i'm willing to
bet a good chunk of this
uh interstate compact um we're already
doing it
because an earlier version has it
that's just a guess on my part but um i
think i'm not solid grounded
representative marsh
mr chair i'm sorry i can't give you a
page in line reference because i run out
of tower in my laptop
but but uh there is another section of
the interstate contact
which uh outlines the court procedures
which must be followed
if a ascending state is giving up its
authority over
a child which has been sent uh and so
that's very clearly specified in the uh
in the uh bill and uh if somebody wants
to hand you a paper copy i'll be glad to
find you the facebook live
show yes i'm i'm
working on finding also but okay let's
give us a few
minutes to do that
before we move on well actually
by the way it is it's you go to just the
statutes 170 a is the current one that
we have
um mr chairman you haven't
those who are questioning this will want
to pay attention to this discussion and
not have a separate one
i'm says i cannot hear mr chairman
conversation and it's this one
go ahead yes the bill reads on page 15
starting with line 35 in accordance with
its own laws the court in the sending
state shall have authority
it's jurisdiction yes a the child is
reunified with the parent in the
receiving stage with the subject of
allegations
or finances of abuse for neglect only
with the concurrence of the public
child place against the scene in the
receiving state b the child is adopted
c the child reaches the age of majority
under the laws
of state the child achieves legal
independence pursuant to the law of the
senate state
agency of descending state request
termination has obtained
the concurrence of the public child
presence agency receiving state
and uh so i i believe that those are
adequate protections
for children who may be sent to other
jurisdictions
so then it would be fair to assume that
emergency
is exactly that it is representative
weber's
uh example of a child wandering around
barefoot
but not just some arbitrary or keeping a
kid
thank you mr chairman so i'm
my uh concerns are still not alleviated
because there's no language in here that
says
you know oh they can take jurisdiction
for an emergency
and then they need to be sent
immediately back to the original
uh ascending state you know if they take
jurisdiction over the
to over the child do they not then have
the authority to
place that child in a foster home
in the state where they have
jurisdiction
if this is the chairman it would seem to
me that once the emergency
is over we revert to the rules that are
in place
vis-a-vis the sending state in the
receiving state emergency is over the
child
is back where the child should be and
has shoes on
and so the emergency is over so we
continue as as we have been
i mean that's exactly why but what if
the emergency
is they deem the parent that the sending
state
sent it to is somehow unfit so they take
emergency custody of the child which is
very common
to happen now they have jurisdiction
over that child
and do they there's is there something
to require them to send the child back
to the sending state for their
jurisdiction to
representative marsh uh yes if they
those states have adopted the interstate
compact they have to abide by provisions
that's why we have an interstate company
if there was not an in this big contract
you'd be correct
that there would be no reason that the
other state you have to send each other
right representative
snow you've been a social worker for a
but i also think one of the factors we
should look at since 2009
new hampshire has brought into place
what's called a child advocate that wore
up
and i think the current role you know
the substantial
i think we have to kind of evaluate that
but that's a
big change from where we were in this
2009 original
contemplated
well actually what we have before us is
the 2009
version yeah yeah and your experience
with the
child's advocate is now we have a person
who does exactly what the title says
advocates for the child so if this child
is centering young the advocate still
has interest in their child my
assumption is that if a decision is made
say by dcyf to send a child
somewhere else that child advocate
would play a role in this and could
either recommend
or discontinue the action
that's her role to look what's best for
the child
what is going to best protect this child
you know decision made by one agency
would not necessarily go
into that situation thank you
representative snow do i see your hand
on the screen yes representative weber
and mostly representative shapiro
okay thank you representative uh weber
you may go first and then representative
shapiro
i i think we need to be a little careful
with the role of the
uh office of the child advocate that
office is not automatically
involved in every case but
the fact is that whether a child is in
placement here
or in placement in another state
if a parent or family member is
concerned about that child are concerned
about how dcyf
has handled a particular case they can
certainly and certainly will receive a
complaint here
and follow up on that and i certainly
have
referred a number of people who have
concerns about how their case has been
handled
by dcyf both to the ombudsman within
dcyf
and to the office of child advocacy
so that whatever issues have come up can
be resolved and and they certainly will
help in that way
and uh the other thing i will say is
that
in my experience if the office of the
child
advocate perceives a pattern that they
find
troubling on behalf of a group of
children
they have been fierce in detailing
those problems and working to get them
fixed whether that requires a
legislative fix or something else
thank you representative the chair
recognizes representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman um as a
as a former family and child therapist
and also as a former child protective
services worker in vermont
i think it's important while we're while
we're analyzing this and being careful
that it's written well we should also
keep in mind that
without new hampshire being part of this
we would be
um in great trouble this is something
that's used fairly frequently
it's used um you know it's used
as representative weber said to place
kids with
um family rather than in institutions
and i think that without joining this
impact
this compact um we would be at a great
disadvantage
and there are many many checks and
balances if things go wrong
including um the courts because
kids have to be adjudicated to be in the
system
um and families um
can go to court and there are regular
court hearings so i think there are many
checks and balances
and we have to remember that this is um
a very important thing for us to have um
because it really serves the well-being
of children
and families representative shapiro am i
correct to infer
from what you said that we are not
uh my understanding from this discussion
is that we are in an inter
in a compact but it is uh an older
compact
um and this is an attempt to update it
okay
it would be difficult for me not having
the older compact in front of me
to know where we are simply carrying
over things and where we are making
positive changes mr chair may i speak to
that
i represent to that point yes
representative conor yes
um the website has all this on it
um if you and this was actually what
christina dyer initially sent us she
sent us a link to it
it's a a p as in peterhsa.org
anybody you can also google interstate
compact for placement of children
um but it's yes we are part of that all
50 states are part of this compact
already
this is simply an uh a new version
and it is actually again does not go
into effect until 35 states
11 states have approved the new version
um it's been introduced in arizona it's
been passed by one chamber in kentucky
but their map is not up to date because
they don't have it enacted in our chain
you know that it's been passed in our
chamber they do have a side-by-side
comparison
if desired i could send that link to the
entire committee
um and that would give you that i would
appreciate that for my edification i'm
not sure that
uh we would have it in time um i really
do hope you get done with this today
and not have to come back next week well
a follow-up i do not think we should
delay what we're doing this is just an
update
to bring us up to date the point is we
are already in a compact
that we need i think we should pass this
so we can just be
to the revised new but again it doesn't
going to take effect
until two-thirds of the states uh have
agreed with this and then we had
then we can go ahead and proceed with it
and your statement is we are up to 11
states presently
that is what it says on their website
okay thank you
uh representative representative marsh
please
yes thank you mr chairman i will point
out that people can read the existing
contact in the existing rsa 170-a
colon one and i would also point out
that uh i believe john wade spoke to us
earlier he probably can answer the legal
question
and if not he could quickly get in touch
with rebecca ross
and certain financial representatives
question uh
without any villains
counselor williams can you speak to this
point or
find someone uh chairman uh
absolutely i believe we have attorney
ross uh with us and if she could just
raise her
hand and miss dyer would bring her into
the conversation she's at the ready to
address the questions regarding the
updating of the interstate compact
with the house bring her into the
she's on the way
thank you pam smarling has been shooting
for christina dyer
who had to leave for an emergency
[Music]
good afternoon members of the committee
i'm i'm happy to try to help clarify
i believe representative cushman's
question is if other states would just
be able to take jurisdiction
um and keep it in the course of an
emergency is that correct
yes that's correct i believe
the the answer would be no um and
part of being a member of the commission
and
being part of an icpc state is
that that would not be able to happen
once the 35 states
um adopt icpc
and or the 2009 version it would
um bring together the commission who
would sit together and
write the essentially the equivalent of
the administrative rules on
the the nuts and bolts and the mechanics
of how all of that would happen
but it doesn't happen um like that today
under the current icpc and it certainly
would not under the
continued icpc um the point is to have
better collaboration and clarity
and communication with the states that
we
partner with not um to allow one state
to trump the other state
and if it were not a dcyf related case
and it were another parenting case or
other type of case there are other
things
like the uniform um custody acts and
other acts that we are involved in that
would also not permit another state
to take jurisdiction over a new
hampshire child
does that address your concern uh
representative kushner do you have a
follow-up question
follow-up question and statement i
suppose
um so there is then in this bill
in this section of the bill concerning
this content
um there is no
way to ensure that the state that takes
over emergency jurisdiction
only maintains it for as long as it
takes to get the child back to
the ascending state
well i think that yes or no question
i believe it depends because it would
have to do with the rules that are not
yet
written as well as the other facts
and circumstances as to why the child
was removed so you've asked if we would
immediately bring
be bringing the child back to new
hampshire and it really would depend on
what type of emergency that was
and if the emergency ceased to exist and
we determined that it was still an
appropriate placement with that relative
out of state that
that child could stay out of state but
it would still be a new hampshire case
in a
new hampshire jurisdiction given the
fact that we
are under the old compact
and presumably the administrative rules
for that
have been written long ago how would you
answer the question
right now we would hear from our partner
in state who's supervising
in the other state and we would work
with them to coordinate a plan of
whether or not placement in that state
was appropriate or if they needed to
come back to new hampshire and whether
or not a hearing
was required or not representative
cushman for follow-up
mr chairman um so i was looking at the
current
statute um and there is no clause
to allow jurisdiction to go to the
receiving state in
an emergency um it only allows them to
have jurisdiction over dealing with
delinquency or crimes committed in that
state
um so this is new language so i would
assume there are no
administrative rules on this particular
topic
i wouldn't make that assumption because
i don't have the compact rules in front
of me
um it wouldn't necessarily be expressly
in the statute this had not been an
issue that had been raised
either this session or the last session
we could do follow-up
research and ask our compact
administrator
but um in in my 15 years of experience
with dcyf this has not been
been a concern when we've had an
emergency arise with the united states
this is the chairman again so it is uh
fair to assume
if we are doing an analysis of
an in a previous iteration of the
compact
we would have to look at both law and
administrative rules to get a full
picture
of all the operational aspects
absolutely i think that would be
for any any law and rule set that we
have
um regulating such an important topic
yes to follow up on that question
would it also be a fair assumption to
say if we pass this version
the 2009 version what we
know is this virgin and what we do not
know
is the administrative rules that are yet
to be developed because
35 states have not ratified that is that
a correct assumption
that's correct and we would want to be a
part of that so by entering it earlier
and joining we would be one of the
states at the table
to be in those discussions where if we
wait and see
we don't get a voice in those
conversations so we would like to
hear of moving forward to a system that
has better protections for children
coming in and out of
new hampshire and that we're able to
have a voice at the table when those are
being created
thank you very much representative snob
well going back
to the psychologist bill that my
colleague mentioned
that we looked at compact around
psychologists being able to
work in other states in emergencies
the only people who can set up rules for
that compact are the people who have
already joined
right and that continues there are now
11 people who are going to be making any
decisions about that it moves a little
bit that's a fact that we ought to keep
in mind
and i think it it's a justification for
some of what uh representative
cushman's concerns are about some of the
yeah yeah thank you representative uh
anyone
seeing no one with a hand up on the
screen
mr chair uh representative cushman has
her hand up
i know that she's she's in my room
and she's on your screen you know this
just goes and goes
to the awards that she's been given
today
thank you mr chairman so just given the
conversation that we had
um i don't feel comfortable having
you know the multiple states and an
interesting compact make the rule that
we
maintain jurisdiction over a child if
they're
if the receiving state takes that in an
emergency
um i that i can't support
this bill i would support if
there was language in there that said
you know they can take jurisdiction in
an emergency
for you know as long as it takes to get
the child
back to either the sending state or
to get in contact with the sending state
and for them to come in
and you know take over the case
representative marsh yes i would like to
point out that pursuant to amendment
h that we just passed these people out
of state do not decorate the rules for
the state of new hampshire
they go through our normal remaking
process
representative mars the chair would ask
i i am familiar with some
interstate compacts and they are written
in that the local state does not have
the right to write its own rules but
must abide by the joint rules would the
amendments
that refer that reserves to new
hampshire the right to write
the rules invalidate our participation
in the compact
uh mr chair what we did is we copied the
current statute and put the references
to the contact
in the new compact in that section of
the village
if you have i'll give you a vacation
line through any piece of paper because
i don't have
because i as i said i do know and one
that i've been working on
uh i know in some compacts we're not
allowed to do that yes uh page two
lines fifteen to sixteen of your
amendments of the amendment parallels
the existing language
in the existing rsa 170 page seven
and allocates human services shall adopt
rules
under article 11 of the contract in
accordance with rsa 541
so i believe that is the correct
procedure and it parallels the existing
language and statute
thank you very much um that just simply
means we have to make sure that
the rules in this state are written
to allow that but they're not in
the bill right right
anyone else want to go to law school
i feel like i'm auditing it's pass fail
uh we are actually on the entire all
focus pages of the bill and not just on
this particular section on interstate
compact
so any questions or comments on
sb 162 as amended
as a whole
i'm assuming we can't make comments
about the other chamber
uh you can make comments about the other
chamber
but in a way that does not wink wink
so i can say i hope we never get a bill
before us with 72 parts again
because it was confusing is that polite
enough
actually i would go with something more
impolite but i'll take that okay
you're here out there um
and just remember they are the junior
body because we had a speaker of the
house in 1684.
and the senate didn't show up until much
later just a fact representative gay
what authority do we have to tell
the other body yeah that there's a limit
on how many items should be in a bill
i mean the only one i can know is okay
i've heard some people say this just
ideal
they won't do it anymore but all we can
do to be polite
is x out sections but it's just too hard
representative weber we don't have any
authority to tell them what to do just
as they don't have any authority to tell
us what to do
but i will say that uh
this is happening because
of the covet emergency and
believe me there are many people in both
parties that deplore
the putting of bills together and mr
williams will testify that when i cha
chaired this committee i had a number of
conversations with him about
not lumping things in together no matter
how non-controversial they seem to begin
with
because people particularly people in
the house
want to take a look at them separately
and judge
each one on their own merits so um i
i think that there's a huge amount of
sentiment
in that direction and uh we can only
talk to our colleagues on the other side
of the wall and
and ask them to go along with that but
these are extraordinary times and
and more often things are more broken
down
um but it's a concern the one recourse
that we have is simply to itl large
bills the difficulty in that is some
very good bills die
and having been widowed that way once or
twice
i think where the conversation is both
wise
and be wise not to do it on open mics
yeah
it's also more difficult than a larger
body
any other any other comments on sb 162
as amended
this is going to lead to a conference
committee okay
well we've got amendments in it there
could yeah
and that's an opportunity to make some
statements about that assuming one of us
is on the conference committee
that's the representative marsh yes i
spoke to the prime sponsor this morning
and if we pass this bill with our
amendment 1402 h
however if i assume
there is the theoretical possibility
that there's a snarky floor amendment
that pulls out something that would have
to pass
and then um it would be assumed that the
senate would
probably not agree and then we would go
to a conference committee and
that would be different that would be
good crazy would break loose
representative weber
but the conference committee by our
rules is only allowed to consider
matters that are in either the senate
version or the house version of the bill
so it does not open everything up to
re-discuss
renegotiation my question my theoretical
was
in the middle obviously but you can't
start
bringing other stuff in um my
theoretical was
we would have a an amendment a hostile
amendment
on the floor that would strip out a
section that we didn't like
and then that pare down version let's
say it's passed
the senate does not like it and could
request
a committee of conference i'm not
advocating for that
i'm not asking you to do that
any other any other comments on the bill
vote on it uh
seeing nothing in the amendment right
seeing none the bill before us is senate
bill 162
1402 h moved
by representative marsh seconded
by representative kenner the clerk
please call the rules thank you
representative marsh representative
mcmahon
yes representative nelson
yes representative acton yes
representative gay yes representative
cushman
now representative folsom yes
representative kelsey
yes representative king yes
representative kobalt no
representative weber yes representative
mckay
representative snow yes representative
knurk
yes representative soloway
yes thank you
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham
yes representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative query yes
representative pearson yes 19-2
19-2 is there objection to consent
yes there is objection to consent
representative march will you work
on the committee report and the
two who voted in the negative
may confer on which will write the
minority report
and as the last time please get that to
me
as soon as you can because they're
really asking for
as much as we can send them um
as soon as we can send it to them
because we've got
a voting session coming up soon so this
ends the executive session
on senate bill 162.
and this actually ends our
work for now mr representative
i just may have redwater
but there's a recent supreme court
decision on what's called the jane doe
case are you all familiar with that
it's going to have some kind of
immediate effects the jane doe case was
one in which
a case was taken to court a patient
who was taken to the emergency room at
mary hitchcock hospital and this happens
all around the state
it's taken to mary hitchcock hospital
and sat there for 17 days
awaiting the opening of a hospital bed
last night there was 30 adults and 20
children waiting
in different words and that's done with
no
probable cause here which by law
is required to be made available for the
patient within three days
detained current practice has been
to say well the tension doesn't stop
until we're
transferring in the state hospital or
another designated receiver
the supreme court has said no the person
needs to be
more immediately transferred right away
to another facility
or at least to have that probable cause
here
to be held in the hospital which makes
sense the hospital association and
everybody else are absolutely against
the idea of having
probable cause here and uh they're doing
a math
i think the hospitals have to deserve a
medal of honor or what they've had to
put up with their emergency room
someone constructed yellow beds like
concrete hospital did and others but
it's a it's a huge problem but they need
to do it the governor
had a press conference earlier this week
if he said well
he is going to he didn't say emergency
but he said he's going to do something
right away
to make sure this doesn't happen and
imply that what we need to do is expand
the number of hospital events that are
available
i had a conversation just prior to all
this with lou d'alessandro who's head of
the finance committee
and he's dead set against seeing any
more hospital events
his statement was when i started working
on this there were three thousand people
at the age of hospital
i don't want to even make any steps back
in the direction
of seeing another city packed up with
hillary
somewhere in between some solution is
going to come down and a lot of the
decision making is going to be i think
geared towards this committee
so we need to start to think about how
we're going to respond
to what decisions are getting made
around the state
i am i don't have a foggiest idea what
the best recommendation is
but quite clearly just expanding
hospital beds is not the answer
we already knew from a previous
commission that i served on with
where commissioner came in and said one
of the big problems isn't just
the front door but also the back door
yeah we need to really focus on
easily they've taken some steps they
took the old fieldwork center
and converted that to transitional house
16 beds only the
fact of the matter is the responsibility
ultimately is going to follow a mental
health system
that is currently grossly underfunded
and severely understaffed
and you know a lot of them would like to
open
more traditional housing
but the formulas used by the state of
new hampshire to fund those
means you agreed to take on a lot of
responsibility
[Music]
so i just bring it up i mean it's not
exactly great news for everybody but the
lawsuit
has come in the governor has been on the
press conference to make an announcement
i don't know what's going to happen i'm
sure
before murray chevinette who's had to
sharpen us through this crisis he's
probably
about to tear apparel well
no i the only good thing about it is
poor laurie i don't think has
been in their new office up at the brown
building
since she took office and i think she's
spending all her time over with
the crisis center maybe she'll have to
introduce yourself to a new office to
begin to deal with this
but i really am concerned that
you knocked it off in the wrong floor to
head off in the wrong direction
and there's a lot of people here they'll
already be
you have no idea to be very very
disturbed quite sick
and to be quarantined in an emergency
room two or three days
two or three weeks or even longer in
some cases
with all the other happenings that are
going on seeing people come in
to drug overdoses people coming into
severe accidents
sometimes they're parked in the halls
sometimes they're parked in another
building there's very little
treatment it said except to give them
sit me down medicine
somebody that worked with adults and
kids in the mental health system for
50 years extremely painful to me to just
think that that
is a possibility in 2012
up until that day and i was i've been in
the system a long time right now
we never had anybody elderly we always
had room to put them
maybe they had to be held overnight but
they did however
i remember the first call that went out
says we have somebody sitting at
such a hospital we have new beds
anywhere
and everybody was really upset nowadays
nobody's upset
we got the 40 50 and nobody
let's hope that we act on this supreme
court with a responsible way to do
something
representative snow when i was growing
up in massachusetts massachusetts
has been recognized as one of the
pioneers
in building the mental health facilities
in the 19th century
then we realized that well intended as
it was
we over incarcerated the people and i
used that term deliberately
so then there was a move to shut many of
the facilities danvers and
gardner and you know all over the state
of mount bridgewater all over the state
of massachusetts
because the halfway houses would be
built they weren't built
so instead of now calling these people
patients
they're now called street people or
their overflow
in a hospital and you may be
particularly interested to know that
when i went to visit a parishioner
in the emergency room i was grabbed by
the
unit head and said father would you
please
visit a couple of people they were in
the hall they were overflow
waiting and i said thinking of my
encounter with you i better take my
clerical collar off first i don't want
to split them
so a sort of semi-dressed i wound up
spending several hours
being an emergency counselor
in an emergency room because there was
nowhere to put these people so i've been
through this
and yes and
amen to everything that you have said
and that you've long advocated for
and no we are not interested in senator
d'alessandro
in going back to the way we were but we
cannot stay where we
ken and i intend to activate the
mental health caucus to bring attention
to this for the entire
uh legislation we did this
in the last session and it was
very successful it's heartbreaking
that all of the things that we
accomplished seem to have gone to hell
so that those of you that are interested
the reason we're not moving too fast
just to figure out
where to meet so i think maybe
shortly we'll get to go ahead to
uh to go ahead and meet
i've also got a call from nami
which is an outstanding program that
they would like to work with us
on this caucus and provide some staffing
[Music]
thank you for the benefit of those
here and listening um i thought i had
adjourned this meeting
uh but just in case you didn't think i
did this is adjourned
and anybody who wishes to stay for this
for many of us very important
conversation may
and if you don't wish to for any reason
you are free to go
i just say that i have sent out that
links to the
interstate compact and also to the
side-by-side
it's in your email thank you i have
another appliance i would